GOOD AFTERNOON THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS IN NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
FIVE TWO. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
EIGHT FOUR ONE. ZERO THREE FOUR
NINE AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR ONE ZERO
THREE FOUR NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE
MOVED TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. RESTOS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. TWENTY
RECEIVED A LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOUR
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HEAR YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THIS WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR AFTER CONNECTIONS MUTED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL PARDEE
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA PLEASE NOTE THAT
VICE CHAIR CENTER MELENDEZ WILL
NOT BE PRESENT AT AT TODAY'S
HEARING. THERE ARE THREE BILLS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
WILL VOTE ON AT THE END OF OUR
HEARING AND THEY ARE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWO TO SIX BY
SEPTEMBER RAMOS. I NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY BY SOME
MEMBER PATRICK NORRIS AND I AM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWELVE OH
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER KILO WEBER.
THE BILLS WILL BE HEARD IN FILE
ORDER HOWEVER THE FOLDER MAY BE
MODIFIED BECAUSE OF THE VEIL
ABILITY IF THE AUTHORS TO
PRESENT. AND THE NEED TO
COMPLETE THE HEARING AGENDA IN
A TIMELY MANNER. BEFORE YOUR
PRESENTATION THE BILL I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A QUORUM HOWEVER WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE. FOR
BILL TESTIMONY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
ME AS A TWO TIME LIMITS ON THE
BILL TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY MYSELF
AS CHAIR. BUT THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION I'LL PERMIT UP TO
TWO WITNESSES. FOR TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS OR A MAXIMUM OF
FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE. ALL
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FOR OTHERS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY THEY MUST
LIMITED COMMENTED OR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. I DO HOPE TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE HAVE A
DEFINITE IN TIME FOR THE
HEARING I MAY LIMIT THE TOTAL
TIME FOR ALL COMMENTS ON THE
BILL. TO ENSURE THE COMMITTEES
ABLE TO COMPLETE OUR HEARING
AGENDA TODAY. EVERYONE ALSO HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT
TESTIMONY ON ANY BILL BEING
HEARD TODAY ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. SO WITH
THAT- WE ARE WILK BEGAN TO TEN
YOU AS A SUB COMMITTEE WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST AUTHOR AND
MAKE NOTE THAT WE HAVE A SOME
MEMBER GIPSON HERE- SO THAT
WOULD BE ITEM NUMBER. THREE
THIS ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE FORTY TWO BY SUMMER
GIPSON WELCOME- PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
PARAMEDIC AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE FORTY TWO.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR DRAFTING
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING TODAY. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
THROUGHOUT THIS POCESS AND I
HOPE TO COLLABORATE ON A
CONTINUOUS BASIS. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO REMOVE THE COST
BARRIERS FOR PATIENTS WHO NEED
A COLON OSSIPEE REMOVING THESE
BARRIERS WILL HELP CATCH CASES.
OF COLORECTAL CANCER EARLY AND
IMPROVE SURVIVAL RATES
COLORECTAL CANCER IS THE SECOND
HIGHEST CAUSE OF CANCER DEATH
IN THE UNITED STATES IN THE
THIRD MOST COMMON CANCER IN MEN
AND WOMEN. HOWEVER THIS CANCER
IS THE MOST PREVENTABLE WITH
SCREENING AND EARLY DETECTION
AB THREE FORTY TWO WILL REMOVE
THE COPAY FOR THE FOLLOW UP
COLONOSCOPY. WHICH WILL
INCREASE COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING AND SURVIVAL BY
INCREASING THE AFFORDABILITY OF
THE FOUR FOUR FOUR OF THE
FOLLOWING CARE THIS BILL WILL
REMOVE THE BARRIER FOR SENIORS.
AND MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
WHO COULD NOT AFFORD THE CARE
THEY NEED LEAVING THEM AT RISK.
FOR AND DEATH BY THIS
PREVENTABLE DISEASE. THE WITH
ME TODAY TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY. THE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FORTY TWO IS THIS AUTUMN-
SMITH WHO WILL WHO IS WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY ACTION
NETWORK AND DR- DANIEL DAVID
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT. A BOARD
OF DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CALLED OX TO BE A COLORECTAL
CANCER COALITION- C. FOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF SUMMER GIPSON-
SO AGAIN WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR
WHAT TESTIMONY AND- IN SUPPORT-
SO BEGIN WITH AUTUMN OGDEN
SMITH- FROM THERE CAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK-
WHO'S HERE IN PERSON FOR ANY.
OF YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES- TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES OF YOU GO OVER
THAT TICKETS FROM THE OTHER
PERSON'S TIME I'LL GIVE YOU A
TWO MINUTE WARNING WE GET TWO
MINUTES CELLS. ALL RIGHT PLEASE
BEGIN- THANK YOU SURE MEMBERS
ALTAMONT INCIDENT WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK. HERE'S A
PROBLEM CO SPONSOR OF AB THREE
FORTY TWO. TO ELIMINATE THE-
FOLLOW UP. ON A COST SHARING
FOR PATIENTS WHO NEED. A FOLLOW
UP COLONOSCOPY AFTER A POSITIVE
SCREENING. THE ACA REQUIRES ALL
PRIVATE INSURERS TO COVER
PREVENTIVE SERVICES RECEIVING
AN AIR BE READING. FROM THE
UNITED STATES PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TASK FORCE. WITHOUT
ANY PATIENT COST SHARING. THE
USPSTF HAS ASSIGNED COLOR TO
CANCER SCREENING AND A READING
FOR ADULTS BEGINNING AT AGE
FORTY FIVE. UNTIL AGE SEVENTY
FIVE. THE USPSTF IS STATED THAT
THE COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING
IS NOT COMPLETE AND TELL
PATIENTS WITH POSITIVE RESULTS.
RECEIVE THE REQUIRED MANDATORY
FOLLOW UP COLONOSCOPY. TO RULE
OUT THE PRESENCE OF CANCER OR
PRE CANCEROUS POLYPS. DESPITE
THIS HEALTH PLANS OFTEN REQUIRE
PATIENTS TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
COST SHARING. FOR THE FALL UPON
US COULD BE WHICH CN BE A
BARRIER. TO PATIENTS WHO ARE
COMPLETING THE CLERK OF CANCER
SCREENING. MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THE INDIVIDUALS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO SEEK HEALTH
SERVICES. INCLUDING PREVENTIVE
SCREENINGS SCREENINGS. WHEN
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO PAY FOR
THOSE SERVICES OUT OF POCKET.
ACS CAN ADVOCATES FOR SET FOR
EVIDENCE BASED SCREENINGS THAT
HELP TO REDUCE CANCER INCIDENCE
AND MORTALITY. THE OVERALL
REDUCTION OF COLOR TO CANCER
INCIDENCE AND MORTALITY RATES
IN THE U. S. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS HAS LARGELY BEEN
ATTRIBUTED. TO THE INCREASING
UPTAKE IN PREVENTATIVE
SCREENINGS. AND LIMITING OUT OF
POCKET COST SHARING FOR THE
FOLLOW UP COLONOSCOPY. WILL
ELIMINATED SAID NEVER COMPARE
YOUR TO COLOR TO CANCER
SCREENING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. AND HE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINE DR DANIEL
ANDERSON FROM CALIFORNIA
COLORECTAL CANCER COALITION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. BUT DURING
A CERTAIN LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
ON THE TO PROCEED. OKAY THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AT
EIGHTY THREE FORTY TWO. WHAT IT
CAN TO PROHIBIT COMES LAW-
DOCTOR TO CANNELLA SANDERSON
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLECTED CANCER COALITION.
THIS BILL WILL HELP US IN OUR
MISSION TO SAVE LIVES AND
REDUCE SUFFERING. FROM
COLORECTAL CANCER AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETY CALIFORNIANS ARE
EXPECTED TO DIE FROM. COLON
CANCER THIS IS A PREVENTABLE
TRAGEDY BECAUSE COLON CANCER IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE SCREENING
TESTS OF ALL CANCER SCREENING
TESTS FOR COLORECTAL CANCER
SCREENING EVENT IS SO EFFECTIVE
THAT ONLY SEVENTY PEOPLE AFTER
STARTED SCREENING PROGRAM. THE
VENT TO PREVENT ONE PERSON'S
DEATH FROM COLORECTAL CANCER.
EVEN WITH THIS INCREDIBLY
EFFECTIVE SCREENING ONLY 72% OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN
SCREENED. WE KNOW FROM NUMEROUS
STUDIES WE MUST OFFER BOTH
COLONOSCOPY IN HOME FECAL BLOOD
TESTING TO OUR POPULATION IS
CHEAP HIGH SCREENING RATES. WE
MUST BE SURE IS THIS VEHICLE
TESTS THE TOP PLACE A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON OUR PATIENTS THROUGH
COST SHARING. REQUIRED COLON US
WE WHEN THE VEHICLE THIS IS A
POSITIVE. THERE BEEN NUMEROUS
THAT. THAT FINANCIAL BURDENS
RESULT IN LOWER SCREENING RATES.
THIS BILL IS VERY TIMELY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S- ARE
EXPERIENCING A DROP IN
COLORECTAL CANCER INCIDENCE IN
OUR FORTY FIVE TO SIXTY FOUR
YEAR OLD POPULATION THIS BILL
REMOVES COST SHARING IN THIS
AGE GROUP. AND THEY MUST
INCREASE THEIR COLORECTAL
CANCER SCREENING RIGHT TO
REVERSE THIS DISTURBING TREND-
WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC DECREASE
KALRA CO CANCER SCREENING RATES
BY LIMITING ACCESS TO SCREENING
COLONOSCOPY. HOWEVER CLINICS
IRAN RELIED ON THE MAIL OUT
HOME FECAL TESTING HAD BEEN
ABLE TO MAINTAIN. THEIR
SCREENING RATES AS REPORTED BY
PARK TREE COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER. BY VOTING FOR THIS BILL
YOU CAN INCREASE COLORECTAL
CANCER SCREENING RATES AND SAVE
LIVES WITH INCREASED USE OF THE
FECAL TEST YOU CAN PUT MONEY
BACK IN THE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I'M REQUESTING
YOUR YES VOTE ON THIS BILL HELP
US SAVE LIVES AND REDUCE
SUFFERING FROM COLORECTAL
CANCER. THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
DOCTOR ANDERSON WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY TWO
LOOK SENIOR AND- ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE WE DON'T SEE ANYONE.
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. THREE FORTY TWO NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE FORTY TWO
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER THEY SHOULD BACK IN THE
QUEUE TO SECURE MIND LINE OVER
THE CALL THE PUBLIC IN YOUR
LINE OF STATE YOUR NAME. AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
ONCE AGAIN TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THREE FORTY TWO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WILL NOT GO TO LINE NUMBER.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE BILLION YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS UNDER GOOD CARE ON THE
OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. THANK YOU NOT GOING
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE IS
GONNA. MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS STEVE CORN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS I CAN'T
INTERNATIONAL CANCER ACTION
NETWORK I CAN STRONGLY SUPPORT
OF AB THREE FOUR TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN FOUR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT THAT ANNOUNCEMENT MR
SURELY HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENT IS IN QUEUE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
FORTY TWO WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES OR
REGISTER TO GIVE TESTIMONY WILL
BEGIN WITH ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SCENE ON FORTY TWO OR
THREE WAS MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN HONORING TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH A
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY THREE FORTY TWO NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
OPPOSITION THE AB THREE FORTY
TWO PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN THE- BOTTOM OF THE
LINE NUMBER ANY PLACE BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONE ZERO TWO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF THREE FORTY
TWO. MISTER CHAIRMAN AMOUNTS
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT JUST
GIVING UP ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SINCE SARAH GONZALEZ.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THIS IS BECOME AS
WE'VE HEARD THROUGH THE
TESTIMONY OF VERY- UNFORTUNATE
RAMPANT ISSUE AND SO WITH THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AS WELL. AND IT WOULD
MOVE A LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE THANK YOU.
BILLS A MOVE BY CENTER GONZALEZ
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YES CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU
ALSO AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
COOPER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I SHOULD.
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY LAST SEEN NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
SUMMER GIBSON THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH BRING THIS BILL FORD. THIS
REALLY ADDRESSES A GAP IN-
SCREENING COVERAGE THAT- THE
NEED BE COVERED I MEAN I THAT
DID JUST THE FACT THAT SOMEONE
COULD GET INITIAL TEST AND NOT
BE ABLE TO GET THE FULL
ESSENTIALLY VALUATION. FOR
SCREEN FOR SOMETHING
SERIOUSNESS COLON CANCER- THAT
IS A BIG PROBLEM AND REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SO THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU SO. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SECOND SALAS
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANTS- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BUT THAT'S RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM SO SORRY WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE
CAN'T ACTUALLY VOTES YET TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WE WILL-
THAT WILL WILL WILL WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM WILL BEGIN VOTING ON
THE BILL SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REMOVING THE CONSULTANT FOR
REMINDING ME. YEAH. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE. THANK YOU ONE
OF. LIVE IT IT THANK YOU OKAY
ALL RIGHT OKAY LOOKS LIKE IT
APPEARS WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR THE COURT A STEP TO STEP A
QUORUM. I AND HERE AND HERE.
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE
GONZALEZ THERE IS ALWAYS HERE
GROW FEAR GROVE HERE HER TADO
LEYVA LEYVA HERE LEE MON. ROTH
RUBIO WIENER. WIENER HERE OKAY
A GOOD. IT'S ALL NUTS THAT CORN
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED SIR GARCIA
GONZALEZ TECHNICALLY I GUESS
CAN YOU PLEASE REMAKE THE
MOTION NOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'D LIKE TO MAKE THE
MOTION ON- MOVE THE BILL ON AB
THREE FORTY TWO PLEASE THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTION
AGAINST YOU PASS AMENDED BUT
FIRST THE MAN REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HAN HI. I MELENDEZ. EGGMAN
EGGMAN AIKEN SALAS I AM SALAS
AYE GROVE HIGH GROWTH I HER
TADO. LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE LEE
MON ROF RUBIO WIENER. I WIENER
AYE OKAY THAT BILLS CURRENTLY
SIX ZERO PUT THE BILL ON CALL
FOR- ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTERS THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY
SEE WHO'S NEXT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. RIGHT. RIGHT I THINK
WE'RE STILL WAITING OKAY- YES
THE- I THINK YOU'RE A- OKAY S.
C. SUMMER TRIP PLEASE THE WE
GET THE PODIUM ALL CLEANED UP
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OKAY.
THANK YOU SO WILL NEXT NOW MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY BY
SUMMER CARILLO WELCOME PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY
WHICH ALLOWS LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
WHO ARE MOST AT RISK OF CODE
NINETEEN AND HAVE BEEN MOST GET
REST DURING THIS PAST YEAR TO
ACCESS HEALTH CARE SERVICES
WHILE MAINTAINING THEIR DIGNITY
AND FINANCIAL STABILITY. BY
ELIMINATING THE OUTDATED
MEDICAL ASSETS TEST THE CURRENT
MEDICAL ASSETS TO TEST LIMITS
WRONGFULLY PREVENT SENIORS FROM
HAVING ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
WHETHER A CRISIS SUCH AS
EVICTION A LEAKING ROOF FOR A
MAJOR VEHICLE REPAIR ONCE AN
ADULT TURN SIXTY FIVE OR
BECOMES MEDICARE ELIGIBLE THEIR
MENTAL CAL ELIGIBILITY IS
DETERMINED BY THIS RESTRICTIVE
SET OF RULES THAT REQUIRES THEM
TO HAVE MINIMAL ASSETS TO
REMAIN ELIGIBLE THE UNINTENDED
RESULT IS THAT PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO REMAIN MEDICAL ELIGIBLE
DEPLETE ALL OF THE RESOURCES.
TO CONTINUE RECEIVING BENEFITS
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THE STORY
OF AN OLDER ADULTS WHO HAS
MANAGED WHO HAVE AN ANNUAL
INCOME OF SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS WHICH IS UNDER
THE NON MAG I MEDICAL IMAGE
INCOME LIMIT UNFORTUNATELY THIS
SEVENTY FIVE YEAR OLD IS UNABLE
TO QUALIFY. FOR MEDICAL. DURING
SORRY I LOST MY PLACE HERE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS SEVENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD WOMAN IS UNABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR MEDICAL DURING THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE SHE TOOK A
REVERSE MORTGAGE LOAN ON HER ON
HER HOME TO PAY FOR BASIC
NECESSITIES AND MAKE ESSENTIAL
HOME REPAIRS THE REVERSE
MORTGAGE COMBINED WITH OUR
EXISTING ASSETS TOTALED ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
CONSEQUENTLY DISQUALIFYING HER
FROM MEDICAL SERVICES UNDER THE
CURRENT ASSETS LIMITS. AND
LEAVING HER ONLY WITH ONE
VIABLE OPTION TO SPEND DOWN AND
COMPLETELY DEPLETE HER SAVINGS
TO ONLY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE THIS IS JUST
ONE OF MANY STORIES OF
INDIVIDUALS FACING SUCH
CHALLENGES ANTIQUATED POLICIES
LIKE THE MEDICAL ASSETS HAS NOT
ONLY PUT INDIVIDUALS IN SUCH
COMPROMISING POSITIONS BUT ALSO
PREVENT LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. FOR
CREATING ANY KIND OF WELL TO
TRANSFER TO THEIR CHILDREN
THAT'S A WIDENING THE
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH
TRANSFER AMONG PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN THE PAST YEAR WE HAVE
SURVIVED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
WHERE WE HAVE SEEN HOW OLDER
ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE FACED HIGHER
RISK OF COVERT NINETEEN
COMPLICATIONS IN PARTICULAR IT
IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THE
MEDICAL PROGRAMS. DO NOT IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO ENTRY WE
SHOULD BE ELIMINATING THOSE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY VERSUS MAKING
IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO RECEIVE
CARE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE. ON THIS VERY URGENT
ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IS HIMSELF IN
WITH THE- BEDSIDE AT LEGAL
SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES AND
AMIRA ELBOW CHEVY WITH THE
LEGAL AID SOCIETY OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY. THANKS VERY MUCH ERIC
FRIO- MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE OR LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO ASK HIMSELF ON FROM
THAT SENATE LEGAL SERVICES. IN
AMERICA HELP AS SHE- HELP THAT
SHE THAT SHE- WITH THE LEGAL
AID SOCIETY OF SAN MATTEO
COUNTY. WILL BEGIN WITH HIMSELF
ON. TWO MINUTES APIECE. THANK
YOU READY TO TERMINATE. OKAY
SORRY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN HANNAH MEMBERS. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY I'M AN
ADVOCATE FOR BETTER MEDICAL
LEGAL SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES I
HELP OLDER AND DISABLED ADULTS
ACCESS MEDICAL BENEFITS. THIS
WEEK I RECEIVED TWO CALLS FROM
PEOPLE IMPACTED BY THE MEDIC
HOW ASSETS. I SPOKE WITH A
NINETY FIVE YEAR OLD WORLD WAR
TWO VETERANS LIVING IN CLARK
COUNTY. THE ONLY ACCESS TO
WATER IS THROUGH HIS WELL. HE
HAD AN OLD WATER PUMP THE PUMP
WATER FROM HIS WELL WITH HOME.
HE SAVED ENOUGH MONEY TO ENSURE
HE COULD PAY FOR REPAIRS WHEN
THE WATER PUMP BROKE DOWN. WHEN
HE REPORTED THE SAVINGS THE
MEDICO. MEDICO WAS TERMINATED
BECAUSE HE WAS OVER AT THAT. NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN HAVING ACCESS TO WATER
OR ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. IT
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY PASSAGE HE
COULD HAVE BOTH. I SPOKE WITH
MR MISTER RODRIGUEZ. A NINETY
THREE YEAR OLD MAN CARING
CARING FOR HIS NINETY SEVEN
YEAR OLD WIFE WITH SEVERE
DEMENTIA. YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CARE FOR HIS WIFE UNTIL NOW.
MEDICAL CONDITION WORSENED AND
HE NEEDS HELP CARING FOR BOTH
HIMSELF AND HIS WIFE. THE
COUPLE HAVE ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STATE. I FOR MEDICO
AND WITH THE NIGHT BECAUSE OF
THE MONEY IN THEIR ACCOUNT. I
HAD THE UNENVIABLE JOB OF
TELLING HIM THE ONLY WAY TO
QUALIFY FOR MEDICAID. IF THE
SPEND DOWN THEIR EMERGENCY
FUNDS TO THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES. HE
ASKED HOW HE COULD POSSIBLY PAY
THEIR PROPERTY TAXES HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE AND MAINTAIN THEIR
HOME IF THEY LIQUIDATE THEIR
SAVINGS. I HAD NO ANSWERS FOR
HIM. NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO
INTENTIONALLY IMPOVERISH
THEMSELVES TO ACCESS NECESSARY
HEALTH CARE. BUT RESPECTFULLY
URGES YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB
FOUR SEVENTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S BRING ON AMIRA EL
BESSIE BESSIE. I THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY- I'M
RETURNING WITH THE LEGAL AID
SOCIETY OF THEM KILLED COUNTIES
HELP CONSUMER CENTER AND WE IS
THE INDIGENT FOLKS WITH THE
MEDIC HOW- GENERALLY ISSUES AND
ACT KAREN HUGHES. WE REGULARLY
AT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE IN THE
PAST STRUGGLED WITH HOUSING
INSECURITY YOU TO BOOT
INSECURITY AND NUMEROUS OTHER
FINANCIAL HARD HURDLE. AND WE
ARE FREQUENTLY ADVISING ON
SPENDING DOWN COUNTY LAST THAT
IN ORDER TO DROP BELOW THE TWO
TO THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT
THAT LIMIT IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
FOR MEDICAID- FORTUNATELY THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE BAY AREA
MAKES IT VERY HARD FOR THE
FOLKS THAT PUBLISHED ANY TYPE
OF SAFETY NET BECAUSE THEY'RE
FORCED TO CONSISTENTLY STAY.
BELOW THE ACT THAT LIMITS. ONE
SUCH CRIME THANKING US WHAT DID
THEY VETERAN WITH DRUG WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND THE POWER. AT
THE TIME CAME AS HE WAS IN A
LOW SHELTER AND WAS ABLE TO
SAVE A- FIVE. DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO BE TO PAY A FIRST LAST
MONTH'S RENT AND A DEPOSIT ON
AN APARTMENT. HE WAS STUCK IN
THE POSITION OF EITHER SAVINGS
MONEY TO BE ABLE TO GET HIS OWN
PLACE. SACRIFICING HIS MENTAL
HEALTH COVERAGE OR REMAIN
HOUSING IN FUTURE BUT KEEP THE
COVERAGE. WE REPLACEMENT
UNFORTUNATE POSITION OF HAVING
TO TELL HIM HE REALLY HAD NO
OTHER OPTION TO QUALIFY FOR
MEDICAID OTHER THAN TO SPEND
DOWN. TO BELOW THE TWO THOUSAND
DOLLAR LIMIT. HE WAS VERY
CLEARLY RELUCTANT TO DO- HAD
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY ALREADY
BEEN IN PLACE THE VETERAN COULD
HAVE KEPT SAVING IS NOTHING
THEIR HEALTHCARE COVERAGE AND
BEEN ABLE TO AVOID FUTURE.
FUTURE HOUSING INSECURITY.
WE'VE SEEN SO MANY CLIENTS AND
THE MARKET JEWISH AND GRANTED
BY TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO PLEASE VOTE. YES ON EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH NOW MOVES TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AB FOUR SEVENTY OF.
WITH ROOM FORTY- THREE. ON AT-
FORTY TWO OH THREE LET'S MOVE
TO RUN TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON M.
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE. LINES
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SEVENTY NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IF
YOU WISH TO QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
FIRST WE HAVE LINE ONE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION PLEASED
TO BE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. NINE ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NECKLINE. ONE
ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE WHITE SCHEME ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. ONE ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GEN FLORIAN
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND PROUD CO SPONSOR THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. BY IN ONE NINETY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS MALIBU SHEA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. ONE ONE NINETY
EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN ENDS
GO FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. NINE ONE NINETY
NINE. ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TIME I THINK
HEALTH NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
NINE ONE FIFTY FOUR. BUT
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS THIS
IS LISA BARRY WITH THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. ONE TWO ZERO TWO.
THIS IS FRED MAIN ON BEHALF OF
CAL PACE IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SEVENTY THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
ONE TWO HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS CLAIRE RAMSEY
FROM JUSTICE IN AGING PROPER CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY THANK YOU
SIGN. ONE ONE NINETY SIX. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON TO MEET YOUR
THREE WOOD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YEAH. ONE ONE SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY BURNS WITH
SILICON VALLEY INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
THE BECAUSE OF THE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX. HELLO
TWENTY CHANCE ON BEHALF OF
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUYING ONE SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SAMANTHA HER ON
BEHALF OF SAN MATTEO COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
ZERO ONE. THANKS TO A ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIDLEY THOMAS YES.
NINE ONE SIX ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
THAT BRISCOE FROM THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY WE
ARE IN THE FRONT OR. SURE THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COLORS IN Q. IN
SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SEEING THAT LETS GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
ALL RIGHT WE WILL COME BACK TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR SEVENTY.
AGAIN JUST A REMINDER ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO WOULD LIKE TO
PLACE YOURSELF THANK YOU. WE
HAVE KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUEING
AT THIS TIME MISTER CARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LEADER
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME TO
HAVE ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE THE BILL IN HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SEEING NONE
ANYONE AT TWENTY FORTY SEEING
NONE. ARE YOU GUYS JUST WANT TO
SPEAK. OKAY ALL THESE BILLS ARE
GOING UP BY MR MODERATOR CAN
YOU SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE
AB FOUR SEVENTY. CERTAINLY AND
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO WE HAVE NO LINE'S
GOING AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MURRAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I HAVE SENATOR
EGGMAN AND SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CHANNELS SORRY FOR WAITING
BEFORE I. NEED TO LEAVE THE
BUDGET SO- AND I KNOW WE'RE
DOING THIS THE BUDGET BUT I
JUST CAN'T TELL YOU HOW.
IMPORTANT THIS IS AS A AS A
HEALTH CARE SOCIAL WORKER. I
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THE DREADED
SPEND DOWN WITH THE CONSTANT
FEAR OF THE STATE LOOKED BACK.
AND IT IS ABSURD THAT WE MAKE
OUR OUR BILLS VULNERABLE FOLKS
SPEND ALL THEIR SAVINGS IN
ORDER TO GET HEALTH CARE AND
THEN AND THEN THEY CAN'T MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS SOMETIMES-
SO. I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THIS
BILL. AND THINK THE AUTHOR. THE
RUBIO. THANK YOU- I ALSO WANTED
AS COMMENDED THE OTHER FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD THIS IS AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH SO
MANY OF OUR SENIORS AND
ESPECIALLY MY DISTRICT MY
SENIOR CENTERS AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT FOR AWHILE I IT
IS INCREDIBLE HOW YOU KNOW
THERE'S SO MANY BARRIERS
ALREADY EXISTING FOR PEOPLE TO
GET QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND THIS
IS. A IT JUST BREAKS MY HEART
BECAUSE I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TO
IT'S ALMOST LIKE A GAMBLE DO
YOU PUT YOUR MONEY IN YOUR
HEALTH CARE OR DO YOU PUT YOUR
MONEY IN AND YOUR ASSETS TO
KEEP GOING AND SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I ALSO
WANT TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING A
FOURTH GREAT THANK YOU CENTER
RUBIO CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND WITHOUT BEING
RETURNED AND I WANT TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES' COMMENTS FROM
STOCKTON AND- IN. M. CENTER
RUBIO SORRY FOR THAT LOCATION.
M. BUT THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
BILL AND- THAT THE ONLY THING
THAT CAUSED ME PAUSE IS THAT
YOUR PRIMARY WITH. A WITNESS
SAID TO LAR IT'S TULARE. AN
THAT I REPRESENT NOT TOO LARGE.
BUT I'M STILL GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER. CHRIS
SENATOR WIENER. SO WHEN I THINK
OF IT THIS IS. I THINK THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE ISSUES THAT. HAS
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR SO
LONG WITHOUT VARIOUS BILLS
AROUND. CAL WORKS IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOW. IT SAYS. I WISH
BECAUSE WHITE THESE ASSET TYPES
AWAY. COMPLETELY THERE'S LIKE.
TOTAL FANTASY NOTION THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE. LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ARE GONNA. WHEN
THE LOTTERY AND HAVE ALL THIS
MONEY AND NEVERTHELESS GO
THROUGH ALL THE HOOPS TO KEEP
GETTING CAL WORKS- MEDI CAL OR
AT THE HOUSE IT'S JUST IT'S
ABSURD AS THE IMAGES WHILE
YOU'RE RUNNING THIS BILL- AND
WE SHOULD NOT BE. CREATING
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO STAY.
ALIVE IN POVERTY AND SOMEONE AS
YOU KNOW WAS ABLE TO ACCUMULATE
SOME MONEY SO THEY HAVE A
QUESTIONS THAT THEY CAN. HELP
YOU KNOW WITH WHATEVER THEY
NEED IN LIFE- THE IDEA THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
BENEFITS IT IT MAKES NO SENSE
SO THANK YOU FOR DOING. FOR ALL
DURING THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR WIENER. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THE SENATORS FOR
THE AND THE DISCUSSION FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I AM
STARTING MY FOURTH YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND I'VE BEEN
CARRYING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. SINCE I STARTED.
AND I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS
UNTIL WE HAVE UNIVERSAL ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE THIS IS AN ISSUE
OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE AS WELL.
THE FACT THAT. OUR MULTIPLE
POPULATION AND SENIORS HAVE TO
SPEND DOWN EVERY LITTLE BIT OF
SAVINGS AT THE HOUSE SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. ONCE
THEY REACH A CERTAIN AGE IT'S
REALLY REPOSTEROUS AND THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
PERPETUATING SYSTEMIC SYSTEM
OF. CONTINUAL POVERTY IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IN A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES FROM MEDICAL
ASSETS TO CALFRESH AND VARIOUS
OTHER THINGS AND SO. WE HAVE
BEEN AND I WANT TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK BE ADVOCATES.
AND HEALTH FOR ALL AND EVERYONE
THAT'S BEEN WORKING. FOR YEARS
EVEN BEFORE I GOT HERE EVEN
BEFORE MANY OF US GOT ERE. TO
ELIMINATE THE MEDICAL ASSETS
TEST AND TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE TO LIVE
IN DIGNITY TO BE SAFE. AND TO
HAVE A QUALITY LIFE ONCE THEY
REACH. AN OLDER AGE WHICH I
HOPE WE ALL GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO. AND SO THIS ELIMINATING
THE MEDICAL ASSETS TEST-
CREATES PARITY BETWEEN THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM. AND ALLOWS LOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO QUALIFY FOR
MEDICAID ALL WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE MONEY AND
PAY FOR THEIR BILLS ARE HOME
REPAIRS. AND SIMPLY BUILD ON
THEIR EMERGENCY FUNDS IN
PREPARATION FOR ANY ECONOMIC OR
HEALTH CRISIS. NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO BE FORCED TO. CHOOSE
BETWEEN MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY
HEALTH CARE AND PAIN FOR THEIR
EVERYDAY NECESSITIES IN LIFE
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. AND GOT MAD
MUSICAL AUTHOR TO PLEASE IT IS
SUCH A GREAT BILL. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR EGGMAN
AND IT IS A TO PASS THAT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS METAL CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
MELENDEZ. EGGMAN GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I A GROVE GROVE I HER
TADO LEYVA HI LISA I LEóN.
ROTH AYE BROTH AYE RUBIO RUBIO
I WINNER WINNER HI WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAVE A GREAT REST
OF THE DAY ALL RIGHT I THINK WE
ARE HERE IN HEALTH COMMITTEE
LOOKING FOR OFFERS. MISTER
SHORTER COME ON UP. I THINK YOU
ARE PRESENTING FILE ITEM EIGHT
AB TEN FORTY TWO VERY GOOD WHEN
THE PODIUM IS READY. PLEASE
PROCEED AND WELCOME. MEDICARE
THERE A. B. TEN FORTY TO MAKE
SURE NO. AND THIS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDING FIFTY
CARE CHARLES VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA BEFORE PROCEED WITH
MY COMMENTS I WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS OFFERED
BY THIS COMMITTEE. NURSING
HOMES BECAME THE MOST DANGEROUS
PLACE TO LIVE AND WORK DURING
THE COLD AT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WITH NEARLY THIRTEEN THOUSAND
LIVES LOST AT THESE FACILITIES
OVER THE PAST YEAR. BEST NEARLY
ONE IN FOUR CULVERTED NINETEEN
DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO
NEGLIGENCE AND UNSAFE
PRACTICES. THIS BILL PERMITS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO TAKE LEGAL ACTION TO RECOVER
UNPAID NURSING HOME PENALTIES
FROM BAD ACTORS COMMITTING
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS AGAINST
PATIENTS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW US CDPH TO COLLECT
UNPAID PENALTIES. FROM
AFFILIATED BUSINESSES THAT ARE
OWNED OR CONTROLLED BY THE
LICENSEES OF THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. THESE TYPES
OF AFFILIATED BUSINESSES ARE
BETTER KNOWN AS RELATED PARTIES
A RECENT L. A. COUNTY STUDY
ALSO IDENTIFIED COMPLEX
OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES. TIME
MULTIPLE RELATED PARTIES AND
NURSING HOMES TOGETHER HAVE
ALLOW BAD ACTORS TO OBSCURE
FINANCIAL ASSETS AND LIMIT
THEIR LEGAL EXPOSURE TO TRUE
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN EFFECT THESE
LICENSEES HAVE MADE THEIR
BUSINESS STRUCTURES SO
COMPLICATED THAN FORSMAN AND
PENALTIES IS DIFFICULT. AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE'S AN ESTIMATED FIVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN UNPAID
CITATIONS TO NURSING FACILITIES
THAT FAIL TO PAY FOR QUALITY OF
CARE ISSUES. WHEN THREE OF THE
TOP FIVE NURSING HOMES THAT
RECEIVE THE MOST FINDS IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS ARE OWNED BY
LARGE CHAIN STILL ACQUIRING NEW
FACILITIES IT IS CLEAR OUR
CURRENT ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
IS NOT WORKING. BY EXPANDING
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH BACON
HOLD RESPONSE THEY CAN HOLD
THESE INDIVIDUALS RESPONSE FROM
SEARS VIOLATIONS AB TEN FORTY
TWO BILLS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
INCENTIVES ALL PARTIES INVOLVED
IN THE OPERATION NURSING HOMES
TO PROVIDE QUALITY. PATIENT
CARE WITH ME TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL IS HAY SEUSS MISS HAYES TO
SPIRO AND KEPT ME WHITEN. WITH
SEIU. THANK YOU HIS FIRST
MEMBER ALL RIGHT AND I THINK
BOTH OF YOUR ARE IN THE WHICH
ALWAYS X. SO ON EITHER TIFFANY
OR HIS.THIS WHICHEVER ONE OF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. HELLO
I'LL COMMITTEE FOR HEARING OUR
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF AB TEN
FORTY TWO. THE RELATED PARTY
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MY NAME IS HAY
SEUSS WE GET OUR CLASSROOMS. I
AM A CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANT
AND WESTVIEW HEALTH CARE CENTER.
EISLEBEN WE SHE'S RUN BY- PLAN
HEALTH CARE I'M WORK IN THIS
FACILITY FOR THREE YEARS. AB
FORTY TWO IS IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE I HAVE EXPERIENCE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE FACILITY IS
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR EACH
YEAR THAT HAVE EXCITED EXISTED
FOR A LONG TIME BEFORE CORBETT
WE HAVE ALREADY HARD. MARK HAD
STAFFING ISSUES AT THE TIME AND
THE PATIENT WHO ARE. AFFECTED
SORRY I'M NERVOUS YOU'RE DOING
JUST FINE WE CALL THE WE HAVE.
WE HAD TO HAVE THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO COME TO HELP. I WOULD
BE BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH STOCKS. I WAS TAKING
CARE OF FORTY PATIENTS AND THE
NIGHT SHIFT WOULD ONE NURSE.
NOW TO FOR CD USES STAFFING
AGENCY THAT BRING PEOPLE IN
FROM OUT OF STATE. PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS THATARE. PART OF
THE- PROBLEM IS THAT THEY DON'T
PAY THE CNA'S ENOUGH IT IS HARD
TO KEEP. I GET PEOPLE'S THE
STATE FOR AROUND FOURTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR WHEN SHE
PARTICIPATES MORE. DURING THE
CALL BACK WE ONLY GOT HI SAID
THAT PAYS WORKING DIRECTLY IN
THIS SECTION WE SEIZE HELD
RESIDENT WOULD QUALITY. THE
REST OF THE STAFF WOULD NOT GET
HOSTAGE B. FOR DECENT. FOR
THEIR SHIFT. HE WAS VERY HARD
MOVING PATIENTS AROUND TO. EACH
OF THE SECTIONS. WITH SO FEW
STARS. WE HAVE WE WOULD HAVE TO
PUT OR THE RESIDENTS BOLOGNA'S
IN THE PLASTIC A MOVED THEIR
BIDS PEOPLE'S BELONGINGS WOULD
GET LOST THEIR RESIDENT WERE
ALREADY HAVING HARD TIME NOT
SEEN THEY PRIMARILY USED TO
KEEP EVERYONE SAFE FROM CORBETT
WHILE. I DID NOT HAVE TO TAKE
SICK LEAVE FOR QUALITY. I
DIDN'T HAVE TO TAKE TIME OFF
BECAUSE I WAS BURNED OUT. I
SUPPORT AB TEN FORTY TWO
BECAUSE WE NEED TO DO HOLDEN
EMPLOYEES ARE KIND OF
ACCOUNTABLE BY. CLOSING
LOOPHOLES THAT NURSING HOMES
COME PAINS TO PROVE TO PROFIT
WHILE FAILING TO TAKE CARE OF
WORKERS AND RESIDENTS IN THE
FACILITIES AND PROVIDE OUR
SWEET WORDS WE NEED TO TRY.
THANK YOU MS FOR FIGUEROA
CULTURAL AND MISS WHITEN PLEASE
PROCEDURE A LITTLE OVER A
MINUTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
TIFFANY WHITENED WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF. FIFTY
RIGHT WITHOUT THE AID
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF THE BILL
I WON'T TAKE MUCH TIME JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN SORRY FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THE TECHNICAL
MOMENTUM RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
OF GOOD ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NONE MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU CURE ANYONE ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. AB TEN FORTY TO PLEASE.
CERTAINLY THOSE WHO WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE QUEUE UP
IMMEDIATELY WITH A ONE.
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
ONE OF ABOUT ZERO. FIRST WE
HAVE LINED ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JERRY BURNS WITH SO COMPELLING
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER ON I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
THINK WE HAVE SECURE AT THIS
TIME SUIT ONE BRIEF MOMENT FOR
US. I'M SORRY DID YOU SAY
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE YOU'RE A LITTLE HARD TO
HEAR MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LEAD
OPPOSITION OF WHICH WE HAVE
NONE IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING
NONE MISTER MODERATOR FEW CAN
QUEUE UP ANYONE. WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
FORTY TO PLEASE. CERTAINLY IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW OPPOSITION
PLEASE QUEUE UP IMMEDIATELY
WITH A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
BUT I'M SURE WE HAVE NO LINES
GIVING AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
SIR ARE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANYONE
WITH ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER GONZALEZ. WHEN
I SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
TO- THE TWO WITNESSES HE DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB OF JUST
EXPLAINING YOUR EXPERIENCES AND
FOR THAT YOU KNOW HAPPY TO
SUPPORT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE. JUST
REALLY QUICKLY THANK YOU AS
WELL AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
HELP OF. THE DELETED TESTIFIED
IN PERSON SOMETIMES IT MAKES A
BIG DIFFERENCE ON HERE DIRECTLY
FROM YOUR HOME FOR A PERSON OF
EXPERIENCE SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HELPING GIVING YOU DID A GREAT
JOB. WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. AB YOU KNOW MEMBERS FOR
YOU HAVE WITNESSES ARE- IN OUR
NURSING HOME THIS PAST YEAR.
REALLY SHOULD NEVER EVER HAPPEN
AGAIN SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CERTAIN MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK YOU THE MOTION
FROM BY SO. ROOF AND IT IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HAN MELENDEZ EGGMAN
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI GROF. HER
TADO LEYVA BY LEVI LEE MON.
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
COMMITTEE. I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
I THINK YOU WERE HERE TO
PRESENT AB. TEN TWENTY. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON. FIRST A MEDICAL DEBT
IS A SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF
BANKRUPTCIES POVERTY AND RACIAL
INEQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OUR
PREDECESSORS IN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED TWO KEY REFORMS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AT RISK
PERFECT FOR FINANCIAL
DEVASTATION. BOTH THE HOSPITAL
FAIR PRICING ACT AND THE FAIR
DEPT CODE COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT WERE DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTION INTO
COLLECTION AND INCREASED
PATIENT AWARENESS OF FREE AND
DISCOUNTED MEDICAL CARE OF
WHICH FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
THERE IS AVAILABLE AVAILABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA FOR EXACTLY THAT.
IN FACT HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA
MUST BY LAW PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO PATIENTS WHO
RECEIVE MEDICAL SERVICES THAT
ARE UNDER INSURED OR UNINSURED
THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
CONSISTS OF FULL OR PARTIAL
DISCOUNT OF MEDICAL BILLS AND
PAYMENT PLANS. THE HOSPITAL FOR
PRICING I PROVIDES THE MINIMUM
GUIDELINES THAT HOSPITALS MUST
FOLLOW AND OFFERING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO PATIENTS AND
COLLECTING UNPAID ACCOUNTS.
DEBT COLLECTORS TO MUST FOLLOW
THESE RULES. HOWEVER DESPITE
HIS PROTECTIONS PATIENTS ARE
STILL NOT ALWAYS BENEFITING
FROM THE LAW. KAISER HEALTH
NEWS REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BUT DID NOT. A SORRY COULD HAVE
BUT DID NOT PROVIDE A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
CHARITY CARE TO PATIENTS.
PATIENTS REPORTED BEING
DISCHARGED AND RECEIVING
MEDICAL BILLS WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDI CAL OR COULD
HAVE APPLIED FOR CHARITY CARE.
WORSE THE HOSPITAL'S OFTEN SOLD
THOSE PATIENTS ACCOUNT TO
COLLECTION AGENCIES WHICH
FURTHER NEGLECTED TO INFORM
PATIENTS THAT THEY COULD APPLY
FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR BE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE OUT.
CONSEQUENTLY WE HAVE HEARD
TESTIMONY AFTER TESTIMONY FROM
WITNESSES WHO FACED BANKRUPTCY
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO BE HIRED
FOR JOBS WERE UNABLE TO BUT TO
GET LINES OF CREDIT. BECAUSE
I'M A PLACE COLLECTION LAWSUITS
FOR DEBT THAT THEY ACTUALLY
COULD HAVE HAD PAID THROUGH
MEDICAL OR COULD HAVE GOTTEN
SOME KIND OF RELEASE BUT BY
LAW. TO ADDRESS THE GAPS IN
EXISTING LAW AND STRENGTHEN
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS
CONSUMERS AB TEN TWENTY DOES
THE FOLLOWING. IT STRENGTHENS
STATE ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT OF
THE HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING ACT
BY PENALIZING HOSPITALS WHO DO
NOT COMPLY AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
HOSPITALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS DOABLE ACCEPTABLE TO
THEM. PROVIDE PATIENTS WITH
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR BILLS AND HOW TO APPLY
FOR PUBLIC PROGRAMS LIKE
MEDICAL. AS WELL AS CHARITY
CARE AT THE TIME OF JUST CHARGE
AND ALSO ONE OF BILLS SENT TO
COLLECTIONS. WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT. IT'S HOSPITALS FROM
SELLING PATIENT AT. IT EXTENDS
ADVERSE CREDIT REPORTING A
COMMENCEMENT OF CIVIL ACTION.
FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS AFTER THE
INITIAL BILLING. PROGRAMS AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE BEFORE
THEY FILED AGAINST THAT
PATIENT. AND IT RAISES THE
INCOME LEVEL FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. FROM 310050% OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL TO FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL OF THE AFFECTED
PARTIES WE REACH A LOT OF
AGREEMENT WITH A LOT OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF COURSE AS AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND-
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON. R. TRACY DOUGLAS
WITH THAT STATIC LEGAL
SERVICES. EMINA DAVIS WHO'S A
PATIENT WHO WANTS TO SHARE HER
STORY. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO YOUR LEAGUE SUPPORT LEAD
SUPPORT TRACY DOUGLAS YOU WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES. AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO MONIQUE DAVIS AND
YOU'LL HAVE TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU HONOURABLE MEMBERS. THANK
IS A NONPROFIT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION AND WE ARE PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR AB CAN TWENTY. I
WORK IN A MEDICAL LEGAL
PARTNERSHIP. TO HELP PATIENTS
WITH THE LEGAL PROBLEMS THAT
EXACERBATE HEALTH PROBLEMS. IN
MY WORK I HAVE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BUT IF DAVIS WILL
DESCRIBE POWERFULLY. MEDICAL
DEBT HAS DEVASTATING EFFECTS.
IT'S TEN PEOPLE INTO POVERTY.
THEY CAN LIVE THEIR HOUSING
PRODUCTION FOR CLOSURE.
DISTRACTION DEBT PILING UP A
COLLECTION CALLED WORSEN THEIR
HEALTH. IT WHERE THEY MAY BE
FORCED TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY.
YOU KNOW THAT THE LEADING CAUSE
OF CONSUMER BANKRUPTCY. IN
MEDICAL DEBT AB ONE PROVIDE
CONSUMER PROTECTION FOR
PATIENTS IN A NUMBER OF. IT
INCREASE ELIGIBILITY TO HUNDRED
OF THE PRODUCT LINE. IT HAS
STATE OVERSIGHT OF POLICIES TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE. MYERS NOTED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE POLICIES
CAN PATIENTS BY HOSPITAL. IT
ALSO REQUIRES DEBT COLLECTORS
TO SHOW THAT A PATIENT HADN'T
SCREEN FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
WITH FILING A LAWSUIT. IT WOULD
ALSO BAN THE SALE OF MEDICAL
DEBT DEBT BUYERS HOSPITALS WE
CAN CONTROL OVER THAT. YOU'RE
PRETTY CLEAR HI HELLO FROM YOUR
HOSPITAL PROVIDING CARE. WHEN
THEY COULD AND ARE OFTEN
TELLING PATIENTS ABOUT IT
TODAY- BILITY. MY CLIENT EACH
BUILT IN YEARS IT HAD EMERGENCY
CARE OR NEEDED SURGERY FOR A
CONDITION AT NO TIME DID THE
HOSPITAL EVER LET THEM KNOW
ABOUT YOUR CARE. THEY WERE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH. TO BE
REFERRED TO LEGAL AID FOR HELP.
L'ACTION NOT BE TO TURN TO IN
FACT IT ACTS BEING CARE THE
HOSPITAL ARE REQUIRED TO OFFER.
ANSHEL FIFTEEN PROCESS SHOULD
NOT BE OKAY IN HER BACK. THAT
IS NOT THE ONLY LEGAL AID OR
ANYTHING OR THE PROBLEM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LEGAL. REPORT
INCHES. THE TIME COME TO STERN
THE HOT CORPORATION ACT. EVEN
THOUGH WHO DON'T HAVE A PROGRAM
LIKE MINE AND AS IN. THE REASON
WE RESPECT REQUEST YOUR I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOW WILL ON TO OUR
SIR WOULDN'T. IS MONIQUE DAVIS
ON THE LINE. YES MONIQUE DAVIS
IS HERE THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN-
I THANK YOU SO MANY TONY DAVIS
AND I LIVE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTY FIVE SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY TWO- IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A RARE BONE
MARROW DISORDER. I HAD NEVER
BEEN SICK BEFORE AND I WAS AT
THE TIME OF MY LIFE AND MY
CAREER. I WAS TREATED OVER FIVE
SEPARATE HOSPITALS BEFORE
RECEIVE THE CHEMOTHERAPY AND
STEM CELL TRANSPLANT REQUIRED.
MULTIPLE TIMES I WAS RUSHED TO
THE HOSPITAL IN AN EMERGENCY
EACH TIME I WAS ADMITTED AND
STAYED FOR AT LEAST A WEEK OR
MORE. I WAS SEEN AT UC IRVINE
LA OF. LA PALMA INTERNET
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL MEMORIALCARE
ORANGE COAST MEDICAL CENTER. ON
ANAHEIM REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER
AND WEST ANAHEIM MEDICAL CENTER-
I WAS DEATHLY ILL FOR OVER A
YEAR AND A HALF IN AND OUT OF
HOSPITALS NOT RECEIVING THE
CORRECT TREATMENT AND EACH TIME
BEING SENT HOME WITHOUT THE
PROPER DIAGNOSIS. AND
ACCUMULATING MORE MORE MEDICAL
DEBT. I COULD NOT WORK AND MY
HUSBAND HAD TO- TAKE TEMPORARY
LEAVE AND MAKE AND MISS WORK TO
CARE FOR ME. WHILE AT MEMORIAL
CARE THEY TOLD MY HUSBAND TO
BORROW MONEY FROM MY FAMILY
MEMBERS AND PAY OUT OF POCKET
BEFORE THEY WILL CONTINUE MY
TREATMENT. NONE OF THE
HOSPITALS INFORMED US OF ANY
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL HELP OR
RESOURCES. WE STARTED TO
RECEIVE NUMEROUS HOSPITAL BILLS
IN THE MAIL AND PHONE CALLS
THEY WOULD CALL ME WHILE I WAS
STILL IN THE HOSPITAL THEY WILL
CALL MY HUSBAND AT WORK
DEMANDING PAYMENT. WE WERE
SCARED WE FELT ALONE AND
TERRIFIED AND AT TIMES I
THOUGHT MAYBE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER IF I HAD JUST DIED
AND MY HUSBAND WOULD HAVE TO.
THE ADDED STRESS OF CARING FOR
ME AND THEN THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN OF NEWS WHILE. THE BILL
NOTED IN THE CALLS INCREASED
AND THEY TURNED US OVER TO
COLLECTIONS AGENCIES REPORTING
NEGATIVE CREDIT ACTIVITY. THIS
IS IMPACTED MY ABILITY- TO GAIN
NEW EMPLOYMENT AND A NONPROFIT
SUPPORTING HOUSING. AND SOCIAL
SERVICES EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE-
WAS IT MY FAULT THAT I BECAME
ILL IT MIGHT BE MORE IMPORTANT
IN MY LIFE- IT WAS NOT ME WHO I
WOULD CONTACT YOUR I CONTACTED
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER THAT I
FOUND OUT THAT I SHOULD'VE
GOTTEN HELP. FROM HOSPITALS TO
REDUCE MY BILLS AND OFFER ME A
PAYMENT PLANS DAVIS I'M GONNA I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YEAH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION FOR BILL EIGHTY
TEN TWENTY. THANKS VERY MUCH
STATUS- THE DAVIS WITH THAT
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO DIGITAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
TWENTY WILL BEGIN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE SEEN ON ONE FOR
TWO OR THREE OF US MOVED TO RUN
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN ON RAN
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB. TEN TWENTY NAME WORKSTATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU
DOESN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW LET'S
GET A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
FIRST WE HAVE LINE ONE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON IT'S A GREAT PAIRING
WITH THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB TEN
TWENTY AN ACT WHERE I THOUGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CANDICE'S NGT ACTS ON
BEHALF OF YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN SUPPORT I JUST DIDN'T
MAKE AGE AN OUNCE. BANKS NEXT
LINE. ONE TWO ONE ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON YES MEAN PALETTE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. NINE TWO
ONE TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
JENNIFER LORIEN BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN TWENTY
THIRTY NEXT LINE. NINE TWO ZERO
SEVEN. CAN MEMBERS TELLING
AGAIN SAYS WITH CORPORATE ANTI
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
YOU NEXT TIME. LINE ONE NINETY
SIX. THREE TWO THREE WOULD
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN- FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANKS VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE
DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION BOTH ON
THE TELEPHONIC LINES A
MODERATOR. PLEASE BRING ON
DAVID REID FROM RECEIVABLES
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
INTERNATIONAL AND CLIFF BURKE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COLLECTORS WHO EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TOTAL FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN THE BOTH OF YOU SO ONE
GOES OVER THE TAKES LESS TIME
OFF- SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH THE DAVID READ. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID REID
AND I'M GENERAL COUNSEL AT THE
RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL. ARMY
I SUPPOSE IN AB TEN TWENTY TWO
TO A SINGLE SENTENCE IN THIS
EIGHTEEN PAGE BILL. THE
SENTENCE APPEARS ON PAGE TWELVE
ONE THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY THREE
AND READS A HOSPITAL SHALL NOT
SELL PATIENT THAT TOO WITHOUT
BUYER. AB TEN TWENTY SIX TO SET
HIGHER STANDARDS FOR THE
COLLECTION POSSIBLE THAT FOR
BOTH HOSPITALS AND COLLECTORS.
THIS IS A GOAL THAT ARMY I
WHOLE HEARTEDLY SUPPORTS
HOWEVER UNDER THE BILL DEBT
BUYING COMPANIES WHICH ARMY I
REPRESENTS WOULD BE PROHIBITED
FROM EVEN ATTEMPTING TO MEET
ANY STANDARD. BECAUSE THESE
BUSINESSES WOULD BE STATUTORILY
BANNED FROM PARTICIPATING. IN
THIS HIGHLY REGULATED
MARKETPLACE. ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY ARMY I SUPPORTS THE MORE
RIGOROUS STANDARDS CONTAINED IN
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE ARMY I HAS
ALREADY ADOPTED HIGHER
STANDARDS FOR DEBT BUYING
COMPANIES WHO ARE PURCHASING
AND COLLECTING. ON POSSIBLE
THAT THIS PART OF ARMENIA IS
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
IN FACT ARMY EYES STANDARDS
WILL STILL GO ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT THIS BILL IS REQUIRING
THAT HOSPITALS AND COLLECTION
AGENCIES WHO ARE STILL
PERMITTED TO COLLECT HOSPITAL
THAT. ARMY EYES HIGHER
STANDARDS HAS RESULTED IN
RECORD LOW PATIENT COMPLAINTS
AGAINST MEDICAL DEBT BUYING
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
ANALYZING THE FEDERAL CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU'S
CONSUMER COMPLAINT PORTAL ARMY
I FOUND A TOOL ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY COMPLAINTS
IN CALIFORNIA'S CONCERNING
MEDICAL DEBT. OF WHICH ONLY
TWELVE COMPLAINTS WHICH IS LESS
THAN 1% WERE AGAINST MEDICAL
DEBT BUYERS. SIMPLY PUT THERE
IS NO POLICY REASON TO TAKE THE
EXTRAORDINARY STEP OF
PROHIBITING THE MOST COMPLIANT
SECTOR OF THE INDUSTRY FROM
BEING ABLE TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN CONCLUSION THIS
IS A GOOD BILL AND WORTHY OF
YOUR SUPPORT ALL ARMY I IS
REQUESTING IS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SIX ONE SENTENCE IN
THE EIGHTEEN PAGE BILL. ARMY
EYES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WOULD
NOT ONLY HOLD DEBT BUYING
COMPANIES TO THE SAME STANDARDS
THIS BILL HOLDS HOSPITALS AND
COLLECTION AGENCIES. BUT WOULD
ADD ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS YOU
MAY HAVE SET THE. BAR EVEN
HIGHER THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH IN OUTLOOK MOVE ON TO
CLIFF BERG FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COLLECTORS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CLIFF BURKE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COLLECTORS. OFF FIRST OFF I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORT
THE- AUTHOR IN SPONSORED
CONTENT HERE OF ENSURING THAT
CONSUMERS GET ADEQUATE
INFORMATION ABOUT. THE CHARITY
CARE AND OTHER FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO AVOID THE-
NATIONAL CRISIS IS THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS HEARD ABOUT NINE
FACT WE DO NOT WANT THOSE KINDS
OF. ACCOUNTS IN THE SYSTEM. I
AM ALSO PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
YOU WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE BILL'S SPONSORS
IN AGREEING TO AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCERNS RELATED TO OPERATIONAL
ISSUES IN IMPLEMENTATION WE ARE
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES. AND
BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR IN DECATUR
DEBTS THAT YOU WILL TAKE. OUR
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS THAT WE
WILL NO LONGER BE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL- WHEN THOSE AMENDMENTS
GO INTO THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S TIME.
THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TEN TWENTY
WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM FOR TWO OR
THREE SEEN ON ROOM FOR TWO OR
THREE OF US MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON ONE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON
THE LINE. WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN CHRIS
PLACE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
IMMEDIATELY IN OPPOSITION ONCE
AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
SHOULD KNOW LINE'S COMING AT
THIS TIME MISTER KERR RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SARAH
GONZALEZ- SO THE CENTER
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- NOW
I KNOW THE- I GUESS ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION. IT'S CONCERNS ABOUT
THE SELLING TO THAT I THINK
IT'S BEEN SORT OF EXPLAINED IN
THE- ANALYSIS HOWEVER IF YOU
WISH TO ELABORATE ON THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES THAT D. GREAT- BUT
AT THE END OF THIS IS AN AREA
THAT NEEDS MUCH NEED OF REFORM
IN AND- AND- REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I DO THINK SOME OF THE ISSUES
ALSO PERHAPS WOULD BE
ADDRESSING JUDICIARY AND I KNOW
YOU'RE TAKING A SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN
UP IN JUDICIARY. FELT PERHAPS
THAT SOUNDS LIKE WITH THE DRESS
OF LEAST CONCERN OF SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT. BUT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP IN YOUR SUPPORT. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- ANY
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE CONCERNED
WE ARE TAKING AMENDMENTS AND
JUDICIARY. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT UNLIKE CREDIT CARD DEBT
AND OTHER TYPES OF DEBT MEDICAL
THAT IS VERY COMPLICATED. AND A
LOT OF TIMES IT'S REALLY HARD
TO TELL WHO ACTUALLY OWES THE
MONEY- IS IT MONEY THAT
MEDICARE SHOULD BE REIMBURSING
ASSUMING THE HOSPITAL SHOULD
REDUCE THE DEBT. SO WHEN YOU
SELL THE DEBT. YOU REALLY
DISCONNECT THE HOSPITAL NOW
FROM THAT PROCESS AND FOR THE
PATIENT. THEY NO LONGER IN A IN
A POSITION WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE WITH THE
ONES WHO MAY OR MAY NOT EVEN
CONTROL WOULD. BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME OF THE BILLS. SO
KEEPING THAT COLLECTION IS
CLOSE TO THE ORIGINATING
SOURCE. BY ALLOWING THE
HOSPITAL TO ASSIGN THE DEBT
WITH A COMPANY THAT THEY CAN
WORK WITH AND STAYING
COMMUNICATION WITH. WE BELIEVE
IS PARAMOUNT TO- TO MAKING SURE
THAT THE RESOLUTION IS
JUSTIFIED. SO THAT'S WHY THAT
PIECE IS IN THERE. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD REQUEST AND I BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANKS
VERY MUCH SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE FIRST BE RE
REFER TO THE CAMINO JUDICIARY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI MELINDA'S. EGG GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA HI LEE MON. BROTH
ROTH AYE RUBIO. WIENER WIENER
AYE THANK YOU ALL OKAY THAT'S
FINE THE BILL SIR HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I SEE
SUMMER KALRA IS HERE LEAF-
HELLO THE MOVE ON NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY. TWO EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY THREE- BY SEVERAL
KALRA WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLED
THREE TWO TWENTY THREE WELL
ESTABLISHED A CLEAR STANDARD TO
HOLD LICENSE LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DEBTS CAUSED UNDER THE
REGULATORY DUTY OF CARE.
ADDITIONALLY UNCHANGED FOR
TWENTY YEARS EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE ADOPTS A STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATION TO
INCREASE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH COUNTY AMOUNTS.
MOVING FORWARD ROBUST AND CLEAR
NURSING HOME OVERSIGHT BY CDPH
WILL BE CRITICAL. TO AVERT
FURTHER TRAGEDIES THAT ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE COLD IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. CLASS DOUBLY
CITATIONS OF THE MOST SERIOUS
AN ONLY ISSUE THE CDPH CRUISE
OF THE FACILITIES ACTIONS WAS
THE CAUSE OF A RESIDENTS THAT.
THE CURRENT DIRECT PROXIMATE
CAUSE LEGAL STANDARD
DISPATCHERS CREATE
INCONSISTENCY WHEN APPLYING
CLASS W. CITATIONS IN OUR
STATE'S NURSING HOMES BECAUSE
COURTS AND LEGAL EXPERTS HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT DIRECT PROXIMATE
CAUSES CONFUSING AND UNCLEAR.
IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT HAS SINCE REJECTED THE
APPLICATION OF PROXIMATE CAUSE
AND COURTS HAVE SINCE A LOT OF
THE SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR TEST.
THE CHANGES. FACT PROPOSED
UNDER AB THREE TWENTY THREE IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
NURSING HOMES AND FACILITIES
APPEAL ACOSTA POLICE CITATION
IN THE SUPERIOR COURT. THE
STATE HAS THE BURDEN OF PROVING
THE JUDGE MUST APPLY THAT
CAUSATION STANDARD IN STATUTE.
ADDITIONALLY PENALTY AMOUNTS
CREATE A DISINCENTIVE FOR
FACILITIES TO VIOLATE HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT THESE AMOUNTS
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH
INFLATION. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE INCREASES AND REVISES
THOSE STATUTORY AMOUNTS. AS WAS
MENTIONED THE COMMITTEE AND
ALSO THIS IS THE FIFTH YEAR THE
WE HAVE IN GOOD FAITH TRY TO
THREAD THE NEEDLE ON A
COMPROMISE THE CD PH IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT NOW THERE
DOES NOT SEEM TO BE AN
ACCEPTABLE ALTERNATIVE WE CAN
ACCEPT THAT WOULD NOT ALSO
TRIGGER. OPPOSITION FROM C. B.
H. THE PH HAS ASSERTED THAT THE
USE OF FORESEEABILITY
APPROXIMATE BECAUSE- MAYBE
APPROPRIATE WHEN. APPROVING UP
A NEGLIGENCE CAUSE OF ACTION
HOWEVER. CDPH IS REGULATORY
ROLE IS AN ISSUE- CLASS DOUBLE
A. FINISHING CLASS DOUBLE A
CITATION IS DIFFERENT. BASED ON
WHETHER OR NOT THE FACILITY AT
YOUR TO RULES AND REGULATIONS
DESIGNEDTO PROTECT RESIDENTS.
THIS BILL WILL GO TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NEXT. WERE
DISCUSSIONS SURROUNDING WHAT IS
AN APPROPRIATE LEGAL CAUSATION.
FOR C. B. C. PH TO ISSUE ACOSTA.
VIOLATION CAN CONTINUE. WITH ME
TO PROVIDE A TESTIMONY AS
PAMELA LOOP WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND TALK AND
TONI SHE COULD TELL. CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SUMMER KALRA- AND-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ONTO THE
LINE OR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TO FIND SUPPORT
PAMELA LUCINDA FOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND TONI.
TOOK ITSELF FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM WILL BEGIN WITH
PAMELA LOU YOU. HAVE TWO
MINUTES. EACH WITH TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES TOGETHER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I NEED A
LITTLE AND ON THE SENIOR
ATTORNEY AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE. LAST WEEK THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
RELEASED THE DATA SNAPSHOT WITH
FINDINGS THAT WERE ALARMING BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NOT SURPRISING.
THEY FOUND THAT THE OVERALL
MORTALITY RATE IN NURSING HOMES
BOTH OVER 32% IN TWENTY TWENTY.
AND THAT RESIDENTS COLOR BLACK
WHITE MEXICAN ASIAN AMERICANS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BECOME
INFECTED RECOVERED NINETEEN
THAN THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
BUT NOT BUT NOT ALL NURSING
HOMES. TO COVERED NINETEENTH
DEVASTATION COOLEY. NURSING
HOMES HAVE A PROBLEMATIC BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC ONE MORE LIKELY TO
SUFFER OUTBREAKS. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU NOT TO FORGET THE CAN
DOWN THE CLUSTER. THE TIME IS
NOW TO TIGHTEN REGULATION AND
OVERSIGHT OVER THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY HOUSE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA. WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO HAVE A REPEAT
OF THE UNNECESSARY DEATH. AND
SUFFERING THAT WE WITNESSED
THIS PAST YEAR. THE RIGHT
CALIFORNIA RECORD KEEP MISSING
HOME RESIDENTS SAFE EXPLAINS
WHY THE CURRENT LAW FALLS SHORT
OF PROVIDING ADEQUATE
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT. IN OUR
RECORD BE DETAILED HUNDREDS OF
INCONSISTENT RESULTS IN
LICENSING CITATIONS OF NURSING
HOME DEATHS. WE FOUND THAT THE
CURRENT LEGAL STANDARDS
GOVERNING CITATIONS ARE NURSING
HOMES DOCTORS AND LYFT AND
CONFUSING AND LEAD TO THE
UNEVEN AND INSUFFICIENT
PROTECTION OF OTHER THAN.
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE AND
OXYGEN FACTOR STANDARD THE TERM
UNDERSTOOD BY THE LEGAL
COMMUNITY AND WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE CLARITY AND IN TURN
MORE CONSISTENT AND BETTER
LICENSING OVERSIGHT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. OR NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS THE FACILITIES
THAT CARE FOR THEM AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE TWENTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUST NOW
BRING ON TONY A TICKET TELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN AB THREE TWO THREE
I'M TONY CHICKEN JOHN MUSTAPHA
TURNING THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM. YES YOU'RE RIGHT IS
RESIDENTS SUFFERED IMMEASURABLY
LAST YEARAND WE OWE IT TO THEM
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
NURSING HOME CARE. I LAWS AND
REGULATIONS FOR CARE STANDARDS
HAVE BEEN PRETTY GOOD. BEEN
THAT WAY FOR A LONG TIME THE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN ENFORCEMENT
WHICH HAS RANGED FROM
LACKLUSTER CHIU ABYSMAL FOR
DECADES. AB THREE TWENTY THREE
WILL ENHANCE THE CARE PROVIDED
IN NURSING HOME. THE BILLCLARIFIED THE CRITERIA FOR
DELAYS EDUCATION LIVING BETTER
TEACHER THE CONDUCT THAT CAUSES
THE DEATH OF PRESIDENT. AND THE
BILL GIVES A LONG OVERDUE
INFLATIONARY BONTA PENALTY
AMOUNTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
TERMS OF NOT YOU LOADED BY
DEPRECIATING DOLLARS. OKAY
ADDITION SYSTEM IS VERY FLAWED.
THANKS AGAINST NURSING HOMES
CONTINUE TO RISE EVERY YEAR BUT
THE ACTIONS TO ADDRESS THOSE
COMPLAINTS REMAINED PRETTY FLAT
AND LETHARGIC. ABOUT EVERY DAY
I SPEAK TO RESIDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE BEYOND
FRUSTRATED BY THE FAILURE TO
MEANINGFULLY ENFORCED THE RULES
MEANT TO PROTECT THEM. THREE
TWENTY THREE WILL UPDATE THE
LAW TO BRING MORE CONSISTENCY
AND MORE JUSTICE TO
ENFORCEMENT. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE ALSO FITS COMFORTABLY
INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA PROTECT PLAN. THE
PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT AIMS TO
REPAIR BREAKDOWNS IN LONG TERM
CARE EXPOSED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND OF THE TEXAS ONLY
RESIDENTS FROM HARM ENABLE
BUYING FOR POLICY. I. AM EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT I'LL
MOVE ON TO DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE BEGAN FROM FORTY TWO OR
THREE SEEN ON THAT ROOM FOR YOU
TO ISRAEL'S WITH AROUND TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE. WITNESSES WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY THREE NAME OR POSITION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN SURE
SUPPORT IMMEDIATELY. PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FIRST WE HAVE
NINE TO NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JOSH YOUR TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING CARE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION CALCUTTA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. TWO
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS CHRISTIAN RANDABERG DAY
REPRESENTING A R. P. AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXLINE. PINE.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN. AFTERNOON
SHERRY BURNS REPRESENTING
TELECOM VALLEY INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS- COUNTY PLEDGED
STRONG SUPPORT AB THREE TWO
THREE THANK YOU NEXT TIME. NO
FOR THE LINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANKS VERY MUCH NOW MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION SO
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE SHANE LIVING NAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES. TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO BARBARA
GLACIER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION SO EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES TO THE TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MACHINE
WILL BE IN ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH FACILITIES.
REGRETTABLY WE ARE STILL
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED AB THREE
TWENTY THREE BUT- YOU HAVE OPEN
WITH US. ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AS TEAM SPONSORS A BAND-
AMENABLE TO AND TERRIFIC TO
WORK WITH FRANKLY AND THEY'RE
WORKING HARD WITH US. TOWARD
THE COMPROMISED UNFORTUNATELY
AS MISTER KALRA INDICATED WE
KEEP GETTING A ROADBLOCK WITH
CDPH. THE FACT THAT WE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THIS BILL SOME
CLARITY BUT IF THE VIOLATION
WAS A SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR IN THE
DEATH OF A RESIDENT THAT AT A
MINIMUM A CONSEQUENCE OF THIS
VIOLATION BE FORESEEABLE. IN
OTHER WORDS OTHER VIOLATIONS
REASONABLE CONNECTED TO DEATH
HERE BY SIMPLY SAYING THE
VIOLATION WAS A SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR SIMPLY TOO BROAD. SO
CONSEQUENTLY CDPH DOESN'T HAVE
MUCH OF A CASE TO PROVE
REQUIRED A DOUBLE A CITATION.
AGAINST SOMEONE. MEMBERS COUPLE
SECTOR OF THIS WATER LOOK SO
MANY WILL NOW LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND FINES
LOSE BETTER AND STATE. AND
POSSIBLY TO PROTECT CLOSURE. SO
AGAIN JUST OPEN PERSON CLEAR.
OR SEEK TO CHANGE LEGAL HERE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO. AND HARD
WHICH HE OFFICE. TO RETRY. BUT
AT THIS TIME UNFORTUNATELY WE
MUST BE OPPOSE WHAT'S AMENDED
AN ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NUMBER NUMBER GLAZER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BARTER GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL HM HERE J.
DEDICATED TO THE PROVISION OF
HIGH QUALITY STATE PERSON-CENTERED CARE IN ITS MEMBER
HOSPITALS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY. OUR HOSPITAL OPERATE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
DISTINCT PARTS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY. AND WE OPPOSED AB
THREE TWENTY THREE FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY CALIFORNIA
HAS ASIAN HELP THE PHILIPPINES.
HA IF THE TECH REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON OUR WORLD
HOSPITALS THAT OPERATE DISTINCT
PARTS SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
THEY ARE SERVING A HIGH NUMBER
OF MEDICS HELP RESIDENTS.IN
OUR FINANCIALLY VERY GRADUAL.
LOWERING OF THE EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD COULD SUBJECT THE
FACILITY TO HIGHER FEDERAL AND
STATE PENALTIES AND FRANKLY THE
POSSIBILITY OF CLOSURE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST YOUR
NO. VOTE ON EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE. I TO THE LOOK LIKE TO
THANK AUTHOR IN BATHROOM THE
VOLUNTEERS WORKING WITH US NOT
NOT ONLY THIS YEAR BUT IN YEARS
PAST I'M TRYING TO REACH-
COMPROMISED BONUS. AND I KNOW
WILL CERTAINLY ONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT- AT CREEK TODAY WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO LIVE AMENDED ON THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TWO
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE WILL
BE OF ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
ST ON THE ROOM FORTY TWO
THROUGH ITS MATURE INTO A FORTY
SEEN ON ONE TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE TWENTY THREE NAME ORTEGA
POSITIONALLY. CERTAINLY ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IMMEDIATELY.
FIRST WE HAVE LINE TWO ZERO
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAIR
NUMBER KATHY MUST PER WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES NETWORK
AND WE TOO ARE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. I THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. ONE TWO ONE SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXANDRIA SMITH
WITH LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
TOWARD THE REASON STATED BY
CAPTAIN JJ LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA REMAINS OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. COMMENTS BUT BUILT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER LAND CUTE
MISTER CARE THANKS VERY MUCH
MODERATOR LET'S BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OF THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
IT'S BEEN MOVED FIVE CENTERS
WIENER AND CENTER LEYVA
TOGETHER- ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS I.
NEVER KALRA FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT DAY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS. I
THINK AS WE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION ITSELF- YOUR
OPENNESS TO WORKING I KNOW THAT
LAST YEAR WE HAD WORKED
TOGETHER ON A PREVIOUS VERSION
THE BILL WHICH UNFORTUNATELY
VETOED BUT- BUT- YOU KNOW WHAT
I THINK WE NEED TO CLARIFY SOME
OF THESE ISSUES- I THINK YOU
KNOW. AND REALLY APPRECIATE. IT
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO DO- IT
IS GOING TO JUDICIARY WHICH
PERHAPS A BETTER SETTING TO
SORT OUT SOME THE MORE LEGAL
ISSUES. I THINK THAT WHAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO DO IS FIRST OF
COURSE. PROTECT THE FIRST VOTE
ALWAYS FIRST PROTECT PATIENTS
AND- BUT ALSO WE NEED TO BE
SURE THAT- WHEN STILL. AS WE
HOLD NURSING HOMES ACCOUNTABLE
THAT- THAT THAT DAY THAT
THERE'S A CLEAR LINK BETWEEN
THE VIDEO THE EVENTS AND WHAT
HAPPENED BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT. NGUYEN CDPH ESTABLISHES
REGULATIONS THEMSELVES- DAY
HOPEFULLY THEY SHOULD BE BASED
ON THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS THE FACT IF YOU VIOLATE
A REGULATION THAT IS PUTTING
PEOPLE AT RISK AND SO.
FUNDAMENTALLY YOU HAVE TO
VIOLATE REGULATION FIRST BEFORE
YOU CAN EVEN BECOME A
SUBSTANTIAL WHATEVER FACTOR WE
END UP LANDING IT ON SO I JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE. THAT AS
WELL. SO LOOK FOR TO FURTHER
WORK AND YOU DO. BY US OR WILL
BE SOME THE BILL TODAY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER SURE AND MEMBERS
YES FIVE YEARS SO I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS AND- OF THIS
BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THE CBH
IS ABLE TO PROPERLY APPLY
OVERSIGHT. TO LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND- HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FOUND
RESPONSIBLE BUT ALSO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT'S OUR GOAL. IMPROVE
THE QUALITY IN THESE FACILITIES
I WANT TO THANK YOU- MISTER
TURNER STAFF. BUT I ALSO WANT
TO. THANK NOT JUST OUR SPONSORS
AND THE STOP AS HE PH BUT THE
OPPOSITION WHO DID THIS IS
CERTAINLY BEEN. A PROCESSOR
EVERYONE'S WORKED IN GOOD FAITH
EVERYONE'S REALLY TRIED. TO
FIND OF THAT SPOT WHERE WE CAN
ALL AGREE ON THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS HAPPEN UNFORTUNATELY
BUT- I DO WANT TO COMMEND
EVERYONE THAT'S A PART OF THIS
PROCESS SOME OF THAT. STUFF YES
WHEN I BOUGHT RIGHT. THANK YOU
AND IT'S BEEN. A DOUBLE MOVED.
WIENER LEAVE THE MOST IS DUE
FOR THE FOR READING REFER TO
THE- UNDER. ACCUMSAN POLICE
CALL THE ROLL. AND HIGH. I
MELENDEZ. EGGMAN GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I. HER TADO. LEYVA AYE
LEE MOANED. ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE.
THAT BILL HAS SIX VOTES FOR THE
BILL ON CALL ALL RIGHT I THINK
NEXT IS- SOMEONE WERE ARRAIGNED
IN LAW BELIEVES OKAY JUST
TAKING. MY ORDER BILLS HERE. ON
ON HERE. HEY THANK YOU MEMBER
OKAY I GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE
OKAY SO THAT'S ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TEN NINETY FOUR BY SOME
ARAMBULA WELCOME THESE AGAIN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB TEN NINETY FOUR WILL
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM IN
SELECTED GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
DEMOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TO TRAIN
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ON THE COLLECTION AND REPORTING
OF GENDER IDENTITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION INFORMATION IN
CASES OF VIOLENT DEATH SUCH AS
HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE. ACCORDING
TO THE CDC MORE THAN SEVEN
PEOPLE PER HOUR DIE IN THE
UNITED STATES FROM VIOLENT
DEATHS MORE THAN EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DIE FROM HOMICIDE MORE
THAN FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND DIE
FROM SUICIDE. DATA ON VIOLENT
DEATHS CAN BE USED TO BEST
DIRECT RESOURCES TO LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH ENTITIES AND
NONPROFIT VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS
A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
RISK OF VIOLENT DEATH AND AN
INDIVIDUAL'S SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OR GENDER IDENTITY. AN
ESTIMATED FIVE POINT 3% OF
OVERALL ADULT CALIFORNIA
POPULATION IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ.
CURRENTLY NO U. S. JURISDICTION
OR AGENCY ROUTINELY OR
SYSTEMATICALLY COLLECTS
INFORMATION ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S SO GI AT THE TIME
OF DEATH. UNLIKE VETERAN STATUS
OR ETHNICITY DATA COLLECTION
AROUND SEXUAL ORIENTATION IS
NOT REQUIRED TO BE RECORDED AND
GENDER IDENTITY IS ONLY
CAPTURED IN SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. BY TRAINING
CORNERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ON HOW TO GATHER MORTALITY DATA
WITH REGARD TO THE SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY MAKERS
CAN BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND HOW
ORIENTATIONS AND IDENTITIES ARE
UNIQUELY IMPACTED IN THE L. G.
B. T. Q. COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS
HOW T ALLOCATE RESOURCES THAT
WILL HELP TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF PREVENTABLE DEATHS. WE MUST
HAVE BETTER DATA TO UNDERSTAND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR LGBTQ COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY AMONG YOUTH. WHEN IT
COMES TO VIOLENT DEATHS
INCLUDING HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE.
AB TEN NINETY FOUR IS AN
IMPORTANT AND HUMANE STEP AND
ULTIMATELY PREVENTING THESE
DEATHS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN NINETY FOUR OR SAM
BRITTON VICE PRESIDENT OF
ADVOCACY WITH THE TREVOR NOAH
PROJECT AND TOMMY MARTIN. WHO'S
THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR
MUCH SUMMER ARAMBULA. MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE SAM
BRITAIN FROM THE TREVOR PROJECT
AND TAMMY MARTIN FOR QUALITY
CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TO EACH OF TWO MINUTES
TOTAL FORM IT'S TOGETHER. HELLO
MY NAME IS SAM BRINTON MY PHONE
ON THURSDAY AND THEM I SERVE AS
THE VICE PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
THINK OF AN APPEARANCE BUT THE
TREVOR PROJECT NEARING. HEATING
WE PROUD OF BONDURANT AND WE
BUILT A NINETY FOUR ADMITTED A
BILL THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF EXTRICATION AND
GENDERIDENTITY MORTALITY THAT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I DO
NOW THE BILL A DOUBLE TO THE
pGRAPHICALLY AND DEMOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE CALIFORNIA COUNTY TO
TRAIN THE CORNER THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER THAT WILL GIVE US
LIFESAVING MORTALITY DATA. ON
INDICATE VIOLENT DEATH BUT
DEATH AND HOMICIDE ARMYTAGE OF
THE PROJECT HAS SHOWN LBGTQ YOU
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
VIOLENT PARTICULARLY GENDER
MINORITY TRANS AND NON BINARY
OF COLOR. HOWEVER WE DO NOT
KNOW THE RATE OF COMPLETED
SUICIDE OR VIOLENCE LEADING TO
A FATAL INJURY IN THE
POPULATION WHICH LEAVES A WIDE
GAP IN OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY.
COLLECTING THE DATA ABOUT THE
PACK RENDITION AND GENERATE ANY
OTHER VICTIMS OF VIOLENT DEATH
IS NECESSARY FOR CALIFORNIANS
WILL BENEFIT THOSE WHO SEEK TO
ADDRESS THESE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS. THIS DATA WILL ALLOW
RESEARCHERS AND POLICY MAKERS
JUST LIKE YOURSELF TO IDENTIFY
TRENDS AND PATTERNS AFFECTING
LGBTQ PEOPLE THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN OVERLOOKED
AND I LOOKED DIED. AT BIRTH THE
LEGISLATION IN THE NATION THIS
WILL BE A REVOLUTIONARY MOMENT
IN LGBT EQUALITY JOB TODAY THE
BILL LOOK RECOGNIZED IN A
FEDERAL FEDERAL CONGRESSIONAL
PRIDE MONTH EVENT DUE YOU. NEED
TO UNLOCK NOT LEAVE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT COLLECTING
THAT DATA ACCORDING TO RECENT
POLLING CONDUCTED BY MORNING
CONSULT ON BEHALF OF THAT THE
RIVER PROJECT. MORE THAN FOUR
IN FIVE ADULTS FEEL IT IS
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE
EXTRICATION AND GENDER IDENTITY
WHEN EVALUATING THE WITH AYE
AND OTHER VIOLENT DEATH. SO FOR
THE THREE THEN THE TREVOR
PROJECT HUMBLY ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL.
AND NINETY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALEX FOR ON TAMI MY
FROM QUALITY CAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SHARING MEMBER WITH THE
MARTIN BEHALF OF EQUAL HEALTH.
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO URGE YOUR
THE FOR A DATA COLLECTION TO
THE- PLUS COMMUNITY. AND THE-
AND INCLUDES THE DATA A HIGH
PRICE FOR US YOUR ID HOW.
BECAUSE WITHOUT IT DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY REACHING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND WHETHER POLICY
AND PROGRAMS ARE EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
ENOUGH DATA IN THAT SPACE
BECAUSE LGBTQ CLASS DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA HAS HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN
CONSISTENTLY PURSUED ALONGSIDE
OTHER TYPE OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA.
WHICH WE THOUGHT DURING COLD AS
WELL WHEN THE LGBTQ
CLASSCOMMUNITY ADVOCATED ONCE
AGAIN BE RECOGNIZED IN THE
STATE TARGETED DATA COLLECTION
EFFORTS FOR THIS BILL IS
ANOTHER IN A IMPORTANT PIECE
AND- VERY IMPORTANT PUZZLE AND
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY
LEFT BREAK DANCING THAT AFTER.
IN PRINCIPLE CO AUTHORS
INCLUDING SENATOR ADMIN AS WELL
AS A FAMILY MEMBER LOW WHO HAS
A HISTORY OF LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THAT CAN MEET THE COURT TODAY
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
NOW MOVE ON DIGITAL WITH AS A-
OF EIGHTY TWO FOR NINETY FOUR
WILL BEGIN WITH ROOM WITH THE
THIS ROOM. FORTY TWO OH THREE
SAYING NO ONE IN THE STREET-
FOR TWO OR THREE LET'S MOVE
THROUGH IN TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TEN NINETY FOUR.
IN THOSE AND FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IMMEDIATELY
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FIRST WE HAVE LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS PAUL YOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE ONE SIXTY TWO. KELLY BROOK
FROM BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. LINE ONE EIGHT
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WHEN
THEY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT LINE. LINES. TO TWENTY
TWO. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NINE
ONE EIGHT EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS ALEX RODRIGUEZ EASTER YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY EMBRACE ON
THE COURT YOU EXCITE. PINE. TO
TWENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRISTOPHE MAIRE WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN
NINETY FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU
EXLINE. NINE ONE FIVE FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR LYNN
CALLED REPRESENTING COUNT
BLATANT IN THE PARK THANK YOU
EXLINE. LINE ONE NINE SIX. NEW
JERSEY WOULD NOT NEGOTIATION
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU EXLINE. NINE TWO TWO
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER TRIMMERS
THIS IS FRED NOTE WHERE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF STANFORD STANFORD
HEALTH CARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. YOU'RE
HERE WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES
IN Q. THANKS FOR MUCH NOW WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY TEN NINETY
FOUR WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS. LISTED FOR TESTIMONY
SO BEGIN TO ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE ST ON ROUTE FORTY TWO
THREE THIS MOVE TO RUN TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TEN NINETY FOUR NAME ORANGE
ASIAN POSITION ONLY. THOSE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IMMEDIATELY
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
SHONDALAND QUEUEING AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MODERATOR THE SPRING BACK TO
MANY OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SARAH GONZALEZ. THE C. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING THIS FAR
FORD ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS A VERY
CRITICAL BILL- AND ALTHOUGH THE
SIX COUNTIES AREN'T SELECTED
JUST YET I WOULD HOPE THAT ONE
OF THEM WOULD BE IN MY BACKYARD
IT GOT A VERY LARGE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND UNFORTUNATELY IF-
YOU KNOW IF SOMETHING SHOULD
HAPPEN- YOU KNOW I WOULD HOPE
THAT THEY- WE- WE- CAN PROVIDE
MORE DIGNITY IN THE SENSE OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
SMALL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
SEND YOU THE QUOTE YES SIR
RUBIO. I ALSO WANT TO JUST
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS IN
NINETEEN UP MY OFFICE FOLLOWED
THAT THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THIS- AND GATHER INFORMATION
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO GET IT
IS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. OKAY
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. FACING NINE S.%
ARAMBULA I TOO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. I KNOW THAT AS A
FELLOW POSITION WE KNOW THAT
THE FOUNDATION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IS ACTUALLY DATA. SO WE CAN'T
SEE WHAT WE CAN'T MEASURE
RIGHT. ARE WE DON'T KNOW WE
DON'T SEE IT THAT SO VERY
IMPORTANT I KNOW THAT MY GOOD
FRIEND CENTER WIENER AND I'VE
OFTEN BEMOAN THE LACK OF DATA
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. THAT'S
AVAILABLE SO THAT WE CAN BETTER
IDENTIFY. WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO PROVIDE THE KIND OF- AS THE
SUPPORT AND OTHER TYPES OF
PROGRAMMING. TO HELP COMMUNITY
SO. WITH THAT ASSEMBLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
ABOUT. OKAY AND ACTUALLY I
THINK YOU WITH RIGHT. THE TODAY
WHO. OKAY YOUR TURN CENTER
GONZALEZ WILL BE MOVING THE
BILL THE MOTION IS THE PAST THE
FIRST READ BE REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CAN HI. I AM MELINDA'S
EGGMAN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROVE HER TADO. LEYVA LEYVA AYE
LEE MON. FROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
OKAY SO THAT BILLS CURRENTLY
SIX ZERO ALL THE BILL ON CALL
FOR THE NEXT ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN OH FOUR BY
SOMEONE GRAYSON. THANKS ONE OF.
HEY WELCOME THESE BEGIN IF YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS
THE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCEFROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES LAST
SESSION WHEN I AUTHORED A
SIMILAR BILL. I STATED MY
INTENT TO FIND A LONG TERM
FUNDING SOLUTION FOR AIR
AMBULANCE PROVIDERS AND I
BELIEVE THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND A LONG TERM SOLUTION
EMERGENCY AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES SYSTEM THEY
ALSO PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
HOMELAND SECURITY AND DISASTER
RESPONSE INCLUDING THE
EVACUATING OF HELP HOSPITALS IN
THE PATH OF WILD FIRES AND
RESPONDING TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN CRISIS. EVERY YEAR
THAT THE THAT THE PROVISIONS OF
AMADA MUST BE EXTENDED CAUSES A
GREAT DEAL OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY FOR AIR AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE LAST YEAR
DUE TO THE LEGISLATORS LIMITED
ABILITY TO MEET BECAUSE OF
COVERT NINETEEN RESTRICTIONS
THE PROVISIONS OF AMADA EXPIRED
AND THE PROVISIONS OF A MODEL
WILL AGAIN EXPIRE TOMORROW.
MEDI CAL AIR AMBULANCE RATES
HAVE NOT BEEN INCREASED SINCE
THEY WERE INITIALLY ESTABLISHED
IN JULY NINETEEN NINETY THREE
AND AS WITH OTHER EMERGENCY
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
PLACED AN ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC
STRAIN ON PROVIDERS THUS ANY
REDUCTION OF FUNDING PROVIDED
BY AMADA AT THIS TIME WHAT I'M
DOUBLY PLACE THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF MANY EMERGENCY
HELICOPTER BASES AT RISK OF
CLOSING PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND THOSE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS. WHO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF MEDICAL
UTILIZATION A. B. ELEVEN ZERO
FOUR WILL PROVIDE A TEMPORARY
EXTENSION OF AMADA TO ALLOW THE
AIR AMBULANCE PROVIDERS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE LIFESAVING
SERVICES IN THE INTERIM. WHILE
ALSO PROVIDING A LONG OR RATE.
MY WITNESS TODAY CHRIS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AIR MEDICAL
SERVICES ALL RIGHT THANKS SO
MUCH OF SUMMER GRAYSON
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE CHRIS KELLER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AIR
MEDICAL SERVICES YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS STATED MY NAME IS
KRISTEN GELLER AND I COME TODAY
WEARING TWO HATS AND CURRENTLY
THE PRESIDENT OF AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF AIR MEDICAL SERVICES
REPRESENTING ALL MEDICAL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS REACH AIR MEDICAL SERVICES
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICE. I AM HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ELEVEN THERE
AB ELEVEN ZERO FOUR AM AS ONE
OF SEVERAL CO SPONSORS- STATED
ERIN DOING SERVICE PROVIDE.
LIFESAVING EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE MOST
CRITICAL PATIENTS DIRECTLY FROM
TRAUMA CENTERS. IN RURAL AREAS
WHERE EMERGENCY HAPPENING PARK
AND TREATMENT CENTERS ARE IN
DIFFICULT TO REACH PLACES. ARE
OFTEN THE PATIENT ONLY HOPE FOR
RECEIVING EMERGENCY TERTIARY.
CARE IN A TIMELY MANNER. I AM
DOING ARE FACT THE FRENCH PART
OF THE STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES SYSTEM AND
THEY PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
DISASTER RESPONSE AND HOMELAND
SECURITY AND IT'S MOST
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE NO OTHER SAFETY NET IN
PLACE SHOULD THIS HOUSTON PALE.
BILL WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING TOWARD
LIFESAVING POTENTIAL SERVICES
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND OF COURSE MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP ON THAT STAGE. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON ONE OUT OF BHUVAN TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN OH FOUR AGAIN
THROUGH FORTY TWO OR THREE
SINGLE ROOM FORTY TWO INCIDENTS
WITH ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ON
RUNS FIVE FORTY. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISHED US FIGHT
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN OH
FOUR NAME WORKSTATION POSITION
ONLY. IN ONCE AGAIN ONE FOR BY
IS. THOSE AND- ONCE AGAIN ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FIRST WE HAVE
LINED ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH MORTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. LINE. ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN. KARENMEMBERS DOMINIC
MARI ON BEHALF OF THEIR METHODS
FLOODING IN CALIFORNIA CORNIA
NEED BANNERS OF MERCY ERR.
FRAZIER THANKS LINE. NINE TWO
TWO EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
THE OPEN MARKET ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN OH FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. PINE TO
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SOMETIMES ON BEHALF OF
GLOBAL MEDICAL RESPONSE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU EXLINE. PINE. TO TWENTY
SEVEN. CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
DECENT AMOUNT THIS ON BEHALF OF
PEACH I HEALTH AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. I THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN-
FORD THERE'S NO LEAD WHAT
OPPOSITION WITNESS THAT WE HAVE
REGISTERED. SO WE'LL GO IN TO
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE SAY NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
AT THE MICROPHONE THAT'S MR IN
TWENTY FORTY SINGH KNOWN TO.
RUN TWENTY FORTY. OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN OH FOUR
NAME WORKSTATION POSITION ONLY.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
IMMEDIATELY AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
YOUR CARE WE SHOW NO LINE'S
GOING AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATE SPRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SAYING NONE- SO I
THINK SO MUCH CENTER GRAYSON
FOR- I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME APPRECIATE THAT THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO BRING IT UP TO THIS
POINT BUT YOU WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF AS WELL. WHICH LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU TO YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK THIS BILL IS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS IN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE EXCELLENT MISTER MOTION.
OKAY IT'S BEEN ALL RIGHTS- BY
CENTER LEYVA MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI AND I
MELENDEZ EGGMAN GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ A GROVE. FURTADO LEYVA.
LEYVA LEYVA I MON. LIMóN ROTH
ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. THE BILL
CURRENTLY AT SEVEN VOTES WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAN A GRAYSON- THE L.
SUMMER IRWIN THANK YOU. EVEN
WAITING PATIENTLY HERE. LET'S
MOVE ON THE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
SUMMER OR ONE. ZERO ZERO.
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SAID
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WHICH
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH A FULL TIME STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR OF CRISIS SERVICES.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO DEVELOP AN
EFFECTIVE CRISIS CARE SYSTEM
THAT SAVES LIVES AND RESOURCES.
ONE AND SIX CALIFORNIANS LIVE
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS AND A
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED CRISIS
NETWORK IS THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE AND GETTING THESE
CALIFORNIANS THE HELP THEY
NEED. WITH ME TODAY IS ALEX
HAWTHORN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND DANNY
OFFER FROM BOBBY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER IRWIN-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE ALICE HAWTHORNE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
DANNY OFFER FROM THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS. WE
BEGIN WITH- ALEX HAWTHORNE YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES A TOTAL
FOUR MINUTES TOGETHER. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OUT SOFTWARE
IN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
MAJOR. UNTIL TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE CALIFORNIA HAD A
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
PLEASE FUNCTIONS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES INCLUDING
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LANTERN
COUNTRY SHORT ACT WHICH COVERED
INVOLUNTARY PSYCHIATRIC HOLDS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOT SEEN
THIS AUTHORITY EXERCISED AND AS
A RESULT THERE IS INCONSISTENT
APPLICATION OF THE LPS LAW.
RESULTING IN DIFFERENT CIVIL
RIGHTS IN CRISIS SERVICES
DEPENDING ON YOUR LOCATION
WITHIN THE STATE. WELL WE DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE H.
C. S. COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS IN THE STATE ARE
DOING TO BETTER COORDINATE OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM. BEGIN GAPS
REMAIN AND LEADERSHIP IN THE
INVOLUNTARY IN CRISIS DELIVERY
SPACE IS BADLY NEEDED. I
APPRECIATE IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
ONE PLAYER SHIP AND BRING THIS
MATER FOURTEEN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I THANK YOU
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO DANNY
OFFER. YOU PLEASE BRING DANNY
OFFER ON TO THE LINE. I DON'T
TO THE LINE MISTER.
CONNECTIONIST RICHER OKAY ALL
RIGHT HE DOES COME ON THE LINE
NOW LET ME KNOW BUT WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE WILL BEGIN FROM FORTY TWO
OR THREE SAYING ON THE
MICROPHONE OVER FORTY TWO THREE
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SINGERMAN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR US
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. FIRST TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEAR MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. NINE TWO
THREE ZERO. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS THEIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HOPE YOU'RE DISTRICT
COURT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME. ONE
TWO ONE THREE. HI THIS IS
RHIANNON GO ON THE HAVE A
DECEMBER INTEREST HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU EXLINE.
CHEWING OVER THE LINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU AND
AGAIN IS- DANNY OFFER ONLINE
YET. DO NOT SHOW THEIR LINE
DIALED IN FOR US ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU RIGHT THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WE DO
HAVE AS A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- TYLER IN DAY FROM THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S A MODERATOR KEY
PLEASE BRING TYLER RANDY ON
BOARD- FOR TESTIMONY. AND
TECHNICALLY CLOSER TO IN THIS
IS TO BE A YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES BUT YOU DON'T FEEL FREE
TO. NOT USE ALL OF YOU DON'T
NEED TO. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS HI
WE'RE BRINGING WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RECORDS
ASSOCIATION- WRITTEN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH A FULL TIME STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR OF QUITE. A BIT. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ON THE BILL
I WE BELIEVE THAT THE POSITION
ENVISIONED THE BILL. DID NOT
GET THE NEEDS OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND FOR COMMUNITIES
REQUIRING. IRAQ CRISIS SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BALLOT DUPLICATE IT BUT BIG
FIFTEEN OFFERED BY THE AGENT
THE- ENROLLED. UNDER IT BACK
CRISIS DIRECTOR ARE OVERLY
BROAD. AND EXAMPLE- THE BILL
REQUIRES TO CONVENE A STATE AND
LOCAL LEADERS TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE. TECHNICAL HELP
CREDIT REPAIR DELIVERY
SPECTRUM. INCLUDING PERFORMANCE
CRITERION PICK FACT INDICATORS
UTILIZING THE NATIONAL
GUIDELINES FOR QUITE THE
CHARACTER. PUBLISHED BY. U. S.
I'M- NOT GOING TO BE YOU CAN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION TAMPAK. WHICH
THAT STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS
WITH IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE
BAIL. BONDAGE PROVISION CREATES
CHALLENGES FOR COUNTY
GOVERNMENT AT THE CREEK THEN
MANDATE- TO IMPLEMENT EIGHT.
CIVIC MODEL UPRIGHT WITH CARE
NOT READILY APPLICABLE TO
CALIFORNIA. AS AN EXAMPLE
SAMPER GUIDELINES PROVIDE
GROUND TWENTY REGIONAL TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN CRISIS CALL CENTER.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AVAILABILITY
OF CRISES MOBILE RESPONSE TO
ANYONE ANYWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND CRISIS
RESPECTABLE AND PATIENT
RECEIVING FACILITIES. AVAILABLE
IN A HOME LIKE NON HOSPITAL
ENVIRONMENT. WHILE WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A- GOOD GOAL TO
STRIVE FOR IT DOESN'T READILY.
WHAT YOU KNOW IT'S PRACTICAL IN
SMALL AND RURAL COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE WHERE THE AMOUNT OF
CREDIT YOU THERE WHILE. THEY'RE
LONG DISTANCE WITH THE TRAVEL.
AND IN SOME CASES EVEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT OPERATE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. WE BELIEVE
THAT MANDATING A SPECIFIC MODEL
AND A HIGHLY DIVERSE STATE WITH
DIVERSE POPULATION QUITE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA. INTO A COMBAT
READY GOT IN. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL- IS NOT PRACTICAL
ADDITIONALLY BILL WOULD YOU PUT
TO DEATH. OTHER ETHNIC SPEED
WERE. AND DONALD WORLD CLEARLY
ON THAT CRIED SIR. I BEEN EXAM
I THE BILL PATRICK. PREVENTION
AND INTERVENTION- OPINION ALLY
BUT RESPOND ENDING WE BELIEVE
KOBE THE SCOPE OF OUR- THAT SIR
HAS BEEN MANAGE. THANK YOU FOR
THE TODAY AND WE- REQUEST YOUR
NOSE ON THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITH AND- TO. THIS FELLOW AB
THIRTY ONE OPS THROUGH FORTY
TWO- THREE SEEN HIM FOR TWO OR
THREE MOVE THROUGH A TWENTY
FOUR SEEN ON ONE TWO FORTY.
MODERATE PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WHICH
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
DOES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. CHEWING KNOW
LINES COMING UP BUT WE HAVE
BEEN JOINED BY MISTER OFFER
MISTER CARE YES ALL RIGHT WELL.
MISTRUST FOR YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
APOLOGIES FOR THE DELAY- DANNY
UP WITH THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
ON MENTAL ILLNESS. STATE MADE
UP OF FAMILY MEMBERS AS WELL AS
THOSE LIVING WITH A SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS. I'M JUST
INCREASE- WE BASICALLY THE
OPERATIVE WORD HERE THE BILL IS
FOCUS WE BELIEVE WE NEED
SOMEBODY TO FOCUS ON OUR CRISIS
CARE SYSTEM- BE TWENTY NINETEEN
AUDIT OF THE L. YES ACT. SHOWED
MANY GAPS IN THE ACT- ONE OF
THE MOST TROUBLING ONE DOES
THAT. WE HAVE. NO FOLLOW UP
CARE FOR MULTIPLE HOLES SO WE
HAVE PEOPLE COMING OUT ON A
FIFTY ONE FIFTY OVER AND OVER
AGAIN- WITHOUT ANY FOLLOW UP
CARE- WE WOULDN'T ACCEPT THAT
FOR PHYSICAL HEALTH AND WE
CAN'T ACCEPT FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- SO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANKS FOR MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW LET'S BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IS A
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO OKAY IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER EYVA
CENTER RUBIO. WELL THANK YOU-
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'D
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I ALSO. I MEAN
I DO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION STATED BUT I THINK
THAT. ARE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH HER FOR SO LONG IT
DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE IN THE TAX
EVERY. AGE GROUP EVERY SOCIAL
ECONOMIC STATUS AND I THINK
THAT WITH COALBED- WE'RE JUST
GOING TO SEE THE EFFECTS. MANY
MANY YEARS TO COME AND SO I
THINK THERE WAS A TIME TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE COORDINATED AND
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS AND I. I
DO APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I THINK THAT.
IT'S ONLY FITTING THAT WE YOU
KNOW DO IT NOW AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE. THINGS IN PLACE
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE GET
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
AND- WITH THAT I WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL AS WELL. AND ALSO AN
APPROPRIATE AND ALSO BE A CO
AUTHOR BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS. MORE
THAN EVER SELL WITH THAT. RIGHT
WHAT THE BILL. THANK THANK YOU
SO IT'S BEEN DOUBLE MOVE NOW.
CURTAINS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS. OKAY SAY NINE SUMMER
IRWIN FOR SIDE I WANT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I THINK IT'S WHEN YOU
WITNESSES SAID WE DO NEED MORE
FOCUS CERTAINLY AFTER WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING FROM AND SUBSEQUENT
TO WEAR OUT OVR THE PANDEMIC
BUT WHAT THE RACE SUFFERED IN.
THE LONG TERM IMPACTS WEEK WE
DEFINITELY NEED MORE FOCUS ON
CRISIS CARE I WILL SAY THOUGH
IS THAT- YOU'LL BE ABLE HEALTH
DIRECTORS THEY ARE THE PEOPLE
ADMINISTERING MENTAL HEALTH AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THEY'RE
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD SO I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL BE WORKING WITH
THEM TO FIGURE OUT NOW IS THIS
THE- EXACT RIGHT SOLUTION THEY
MENTION THINGS AROUND TO
LOCATION SO FORTH AND PERHAPS
MY ADDRESS SOME OF THIS AND
CLOSE. BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE BRINGING THIS FOCUS AND
THAT WE NEED MORE STATE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS REGARD AS
WELL- SO I CERTAINLY CAN BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY AND-
HOPING THAT- TO DISCUSSIONS
THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE HAVING AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD- WILL
HOPEFULLY BRING HELP TO
CONTINUE TO BRING THAT FOCUS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN OUR
STATE TO HELP PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO- WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AS
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO AND
SENATOR PAN- WE DID TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN ASSEMBLY HEALTH
IN APPROPRIATIONS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF THE AT
COUNTY HEALTH DIRECTORS AND WE
WILL CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM OBVIOUSLY WHAT WE ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW IS NOT WORKING
AND SO IT IS TIME TO AS BOTH OF
YOU MENTIONED PUT MORE FOCUS ON
THE- ON THE ISSUE OF WE
UNDERSTAND. THE IMPORTANT RAIL
THE ROLE THAT THESE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS- PROVIDE AND
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEY
ARE PART OF THE DISCUSSION YOU
KNOW HOW THEY. HAPPEN AND THEY
WILL BE GOING FORWARD. AND WITH
I WAS FOR. ASK DR OF. BOTH
THANK YOU MUCH SO. ONE SO IT'S-
THIS BILL BEEN MOVE BY BOTH SAN
LEYVA AND RUBIO IN THE MOTIONS
TO PASS FIRST BE REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN I AM I AM MELINDA'S EGGMAN
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROVE
FURTADO LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
LIMóN. LIMóN AYE ROTH ROTH
AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE. THE BILL HAS SEVEN
VOTES WHO'VE PUT PUT THE BILL
ON CALL ACTUALLY WANNA TRY
CALLING EGGMAN. EGGMAN NIGHT
OKAY THIRTEEN THIRTY WILL NOW
IT'S EIGHT VOTES. IT VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO. SEE SOME MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS WELCOME SALUTE
SEE YOU ONE THE RULES ON
CONSENT YES ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. AND WE'LL
START WITH A CLEAN PODIUM FIRST
YEAR. OKAY WILL SUMMER
PETRIE-NORRIS WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SAYS THANK YOU
SENATORS I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. AT THIS BILL WILL
ESTABLISH MINIMUM INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSED DRUG
ABUSE RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
FACILITIES AND RECOVERED REFITS
AT RESIDENCES THAT CONTRACT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT. THE GOAL
OF THIS MEASURE IS TO IMPROVE
PATIENT PROTECTIONS AND
INCREASE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
FOR PATIENTS AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES SEEKING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT RIGHT NOW THERE
IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY OR RECOVERY RESIDENTS.
MAINTAIN MINIMUM INSURANCE
COVERAGE LEVELS THE LACK OF
THIS REQUIREMENT PUTS PATIENTS
AS WELL AS WORKERS AT RISK
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA AND
HIS TEAM ON THE SPELL AND HAPPY
TO INTRODUCE FOR SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. MALLORY MICHAEL FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
THANK YOU AND THEN JUST BEFORE
WE BEGIN WITH THE- THE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY I BELIEVE THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS THAT- YES I WOULD
LIKE TO ACCEPT THOSE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
MARKET THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I THINK THEY'RE TAKE I
THINK THEY'LL BE TAKEN UP IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE RIGHT. SELL
SELL OKAY THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
THANKS VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE
ON TO SO I ACTUALLY HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
MEMORY MICHAEL FROM THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SHARON'S AND JERRY
DALY- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM IS DISHING THE
DETECTION PROGRAMS
PROFESSIONALS IS THAT CORRECT.
OKAY AND YOUR OKAY YOU'RE HERE
FOR IN PERSON THERE YOU ARE
OKAY EXCELLENT SO. WE'RE SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
MALLORY MICHAEL- SO MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING UP THE LINE MILLER
MICHAEL FROM DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE TO BEGIN THE
TESTIMONY YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES
AND THEN WILL THEN MOVE ON TO
OUR IN PERSON TESTIMONY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR CANON MEMBERS
OF THE CANADIAN MALLORY MICHAEL
THAT THE LEDGER ACTOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF BINGE THAT
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT INSURANCE.
AS A BILL SPONSORED MICHELLE
ARE LIGHT THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THAT.
MEASURE NOW LARA IS. AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
ENSURE PROPER INSURANCE
STANDARDS THAT. IN THE PAPER
AND BUYING IT FOR CONSUMERS TO
GET TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THEIR STATE BEING ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME WHEN WE THOUGHT
MORE CALIFORNIANS SPEAKING AT
THE EVENT. DUE TO THE COLD THE
NINETEENTH ENDEMIC. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH I NOW
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO SHERRY DALY
FROM CALIFORNIA SOURCE FROM
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS WELCOME. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON OUR RETURN
MEMBERS SHARE DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS REPRESENTING OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
RECOVERY RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
CREEK CALIFORNIA. I AM HERE
TODAY AS AN ENTHUSIASTIC ASK
SUPPORTER OF THE AIMS OF AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AM WHICH TO
RESERVE A FORMAL POSITION WHILE
RESOLVING POTENTIAL ISSUES WITH
THE SIX THAT REFERENCES TO
RECOVERY RESIDENCES. PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
I'M THE RECORD EST SPACE IT IS
STILL QUITE COMMON PROPERTIES
TO ATTEMPT TO FLY UNDER THE
RADAR BY PURCHASING
HOMEOWNER'S. OR RENTERS
INSURANCE POLICIES WHERE THERE
IS NO COMMERCIAL LIABILITY
COVERAGE. AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
WOULD AND THIS UNETHICAL
PRACTICE. THE NEED TO HAVE A
PROBABLY LEVELS OF INSURANCE
RECOVER RESIDENTS IS THREEFOLD
FIRST IS IMPERATIVE THAT
RESIDENTS BE PROTECTED SHOULD
HARM COME TO THE MOP OR THEIR
PROPERTY. SECOND IN ORDER FOR
LANDLORDS TO TRUST OWNERS AND
OPERATORS TO USE THEIR
PROPERTIES FOR RECOVERY
RESIDENTS OPERATIONS. THERE
MUST BE SOME ASSURANCE THREE
HEARD WITHIN THIS. BUT IF
THERE'S PROPERTY DAMAGE OR ANY
SORT OF ACCIDENT INCIDENT
REQUIRING MEDICAL EXPENSES THE
OWNER OF THE PROPERTY WILL NOT
BECOME THE DEEPEST POCKETS AND
ANY ENSUING LAWSUIT THIRDLY AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
RECOVERY RESIDENTS CONTRACTING
WITH COUNTIES SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO HOLD THE LEVELS OF
INSURANCE DESIGNED DECIMATED
THE BILL SO THEY DON'T LOSE IT
SO THAT WE DON'T LOSE GOOD
OPERATORS. WHICH WOULD LEAD TO
A REDUCTION THE NUMBER OF HOMES
AVAILABLE. AS AN EXAMPLE LAST
YEAR WE HAD AN UNFORTUNATE
INCIDENT AT ONE OF OUR
CERTIFIED HOMES. ONE ONE
RESIDENTS ATTACKED ANOTHER.
FORTUNATELY THE OPERATOR
VOLUNTARILY PURCHASE PROPER
LEVELS OF INSURANCE THE VICTIM
WAS COMPENSATED FOR HIS
INJURIES THE OTHER INSURANCE
PLANS. AND THAT FINALLY WENT
HOME STILL EXISTS TODAY HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR THE INSURANCE
POLICY THE RECOVERY RESIDENTS
WOULD LIKELY HAVE FOLDED AND
THE RESIDENTS WOULD HAVE FACED
HOMELESSNESS. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES A CRUCIAL NEED TO
SUSTAIN THIS HOUSING RESOURCE.
WELL RESPECTED COMMITTEE DESIRE
NOT TO TREAT THESE HOMES LIKE
INSTITUTIONS OR VIOLATE
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS OF THE
RESIDENTS IT DOES NOT ENCRYPT
UPON FAIR HOUSING OR DISABILITY
STATUTE. BECAUSE IT ONLY COVERS
ENTITIES TO VOLUNTARILY COME
FORWARD TO ENTER INTO CONTRACTS
WITH THE GOVERNMENT ENTITY IT
SIMPLY SETS THE GROUND RULES
FOR BUSINESSES. TRANSACTIONS
BETWEEN OPERATORS AND COUNTIES
THE CONTRACT WITH WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO INSURED. AT SIX BUT
REFERENCES RECOVERY RESIDENTS
DO NOT CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR LOCAL ZONING.
AND TO MEET WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DETERMINE WHETHER
CLASSIFYING THIS RESIDENCIA
PROPERTY BY BED NUMBERS IS
CONTRARY TO HELP FOR SUPREME
COURT RULING IN CITY OF SANTA
BARBARA VERSUS ADAMSON. WERE BY
A FAMILY IS CONSIDERED A GROUP
OF UNRELATED ADULTS. LIVING
TOGETHER AS A FAMILY WITH NO
CONDITION REGARDING THE SIZE OF
THE FAMILY WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE HOURS OF WORK
ON THIS BILL LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING TO MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S
MOVE ON TO THIS NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PM THROUGH FORTY TWO OR
THREE SEEN ON HOUSE AND ROOM
FOR ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THIS MOVE TO RUN. A FORTY SEEN
ON RUN TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING UP THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB. ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THOSE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE. BY ZERO NOW
FOR US ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO NOW. FIRST A LITTLE
LINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
I'M HAPPY THAT YOU'RE MAYBE IT
WILL HELP DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE AMENDMENTS AGAINST
THEY WERE DETERMINED TO APPOINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK SIGN.
FIND ONE FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU EXLINE. ONE TO THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF TORRANCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. NO FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES FOR
TESTIMONY SO GO TO ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE SEEN ON ROUTE
FORTY TWO THREE LET'S GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEN ARM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHICH A TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION.
TO EIGHTY ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT.
AM ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW
FOR US IF YOU WISH TO GET THE
MAILING IT IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. SURE NO ONE'S COMING AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH KNOWS BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAYS SOME
MEMBER GOOD. SORRY CENTER
GONZALEZ AND IT'S IN A GROUP.
OKAY WE ARE GONNA SAY THANK
YOU- AND I KNOW THE COMMITTEE
HAD WORKED ON THE AMENDMENTS AS
WELL WHICH I THINK WAS VERY-
CLEVER TO DO TO ENSURE THAT THE
GAP OF THE SIX IN LAST- WERE
TAKING CARE OF BUT- ROOM. THIS
IS AN ISSUE WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH YOU KNOW EVEN ON OUR CITY
COUNCILS. SO MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO FIND- SOLUTIONS
FOR THIS SO AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN LEADING ON THIS EFFORTS OF
THANK YOU ASEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AND IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GROVE ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SAYING NINE. A SERVER
VETERANOS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE AND
I KNOW THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AS WELL SO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO. HAVE THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS I THINK THAT.
DOES IT SHE THE AIM THAT YOU
WANT ME TO BILL IN TERMS OF
SHARING THE WE HAVE THAT
PROTECTIONS HEARINGS
COMMISSIONERS WELL WHILE ALSO.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO. INTERFERE WITH PEOPLE'S
LIVING ARRANGEMENTS AND ALSO-
THE- THAT WOULD ONE AND HIT IT-
ACTUALLY AVAILABILITY AS WELL
AS OF RESIDENCES FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION OR
OTHER CHALLENGES SO- WITH THAT.
ASSEMBLY SUPPORTING THE BILL-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON
THAT. ON THIS TOPIC AND TOP ON
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
FIVE. THANKS VERY MUCH- SO.
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GROVE THE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON SHARON'S-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI. I AM MULLIN. EGG EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROW.
GROUP I HER TADO. LEYVA LEYVA
AYE LEE MON. LIMóN AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE. THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS NINE VOTES- WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL. ALL RIGHT
SO IF WE CAN NO SIR JUST KEEPS
JUST NOTIFIED THE MISSING
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TRYING TO LIVE CALLS. NEXT ITEM
IS OUR A CONSENT. AGENDA SO WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS ON CONSENT I
AM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY SIX BY SOMEONE RAMOS I
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
BY. THE MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND I'M NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWELVE
A SEVEN BY. SIMMERING KILLER
WEBER IS THERE A MOTION. OKAY
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED CENTER
EGGMAN- CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
HAN HI AND BYE MELINDA'S EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
A GROVE GROVE BY HER TADO.
LEYVA I BELIEVE I LEóN LIMON
AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE EXTENSION
ONE HAS NINE VOTES WILL PUT OF
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL
ALL RIGHT WE'LL START BEGINNING
TO LIFT THE CALLS. SO WE'LL
START WITH- ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE BY
SUMMER KALRA- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN I ROVE.
HER TADO LIMON LIMON HI PHILLIP
BILL CURRENTLY HAS EIGHT VOTES
WILL HOLD THE BILL ON CALL
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY THREE FORTY TWO BY
SUMMER GIPSON CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT CALVET
HOME AND MAYBE WILL. BACK UP
HERE IF YOU DON'T MIND. THAT'S
THREE OPEN THE ROLE LINE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE BY SEVEN KALRA. CONSOLE
THESE CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ GROVE HER TO.
GROW BY HER TADO I FOR TITLE II
OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT TEN
ZERO. ALL RIGHT NEXT ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THREE FORTY
TWO BY SUMMER GIPSON CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ- HER TADO I
HER TITLE BY LEE MON. LIMON AYE
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO HI THE BILL
IS OUT TEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS AND
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY
BY SOME MEMBER CARILLO
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS CAN HI AND BYE
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE HER
TADO I HER TITLE AYE LIMóN THE
MAN I. MEAN HE'S A- I NEED HELP
IT'S ALMOST ITALIE SORRY TEN
TEN ZERO EIGHT THAT THOSE OUT
TEN ZERO LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS CONSOLE IN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ HER TADO AYE HURTADO
AYE. THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY BY SUMMER
FRIEDMAN CONSULT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE
GROVE GROVE BY HER TADO I HER
TOTAL BY LEE MOON. LIMON AYE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE THAT FILLS OUT
TO TEN ZERO NEXT TIME IS I'M
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY TEN FORTY
TWO BY SUMMER JONES SAWYER.
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. PAN HI CAN I
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH.
GROVE GROVE NO HER TITLE I
TITLE II WE MOAN LIMóN AYE
WIENER. YOU KNOW THERE ARE
WIENER HI OKAY SO THIS IS A
JUST A WHAT'S TALLY DF TEN ZERO
NO NO NO CAN'T BE TEN ZERO NO.
I'M SORRY. NINE ONE. NINE
MINUTES NINE ONE OKAY SORRY
BECAUSE I WASN'T HERE SORRY SO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY TEN
FORTY TWO THE VOTE IS NINE ONE
ALL RIGHT OUT NINE ONE ITEM
NUMBER NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB TEN NINETY FOUR BY SOME
ARAMBULA- CONSULT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GROVE GROVE I HER TADO HER
TITLE I LIMON. LIMON HI THAT
BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS
I'M NUMBER TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN OH
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER GRAYSON
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ. EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE A GROVE GROVE AYE
HURTADO AYE HURTADO AYE THAT
BILLS OUT TEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER IRWIN. ITS OWN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S. GROVE GROVE I HER
TITLE HER TITLE BY THAT BILL IS
OUT TEN IS ZERO THEN WE HAVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- SO
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BECAUSE AND
CALENDAR. MELENDEZ HER TADO
POTATO I CONSENT CALENDARS
ADOPTED TEN ZERO. THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR THIS
HEARING OF THE- SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATED IN THIS
HEARING ON FINGER STAFF AND THE
TECHNICAL STAFF TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE THIS HEARING WORK IF YOU
HAD NOT IF YOU DO NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WENT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THIS AGENDA ON THIS HEARING OF
THE SENATE THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH. WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED.